Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Are 20-somethings really this clinically brain-dead? How could people this stupid possibly get a job, hold a job, let alone be able to go to some resort? These mindless idiots have no knowledge of books, films, art, history, politics, or anything else that normal people would use in small talk on a date. They appear to be completely uneducated, completely uncultured, and massively immature. An extremely sad and pathetic commentary on the current generation.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。20多岁的人真的临床脑死亡了吗？这些蠢货怎么可能找到工作、保住工作，更不用说去度假村了？这些没脑子的白痴对书籍、电影、艺术、历史、政治或其他正常人在约会闲聊时会用到的东西一无所知。他们看起来完全没受过教育，毫无文化，且极其幼稚。这是对当代年轻人极其悲哀和可怜的评价。
Disgraceful. So that, Tom Holland, is a review entitled, Brainless Morons. Was this in the Daily Mail, Dominic? No, it's on IMDB. It's a review of Love Island. It actually reads very like some of the reviews that academics write about The Rest Is History.
可耻。那么，汤姆·霍兰德，这是一篇题为《无脑白痴》的评论。这是在《每日邮报》上看到的吗，多米尼克？不，是在IMDB上。这是对《恋爱岛》（Love Island）的评论。它读起来确实很像一些学者对《历史的余味》所写的评论。
It does, I was just thinking that. Anyway, so that's Love Island, the great television sensation of our times. And Tom, last year we did a Restless History special themed around Love Island. We did. And you enjoyed it so much you wanted to do it again. Well they do Love Island every summer. Right. So if they do Love Island every summer we should do historical Love Island every summer. Yes. So last year's winners were Stanley Baldwin, your great hero, 1930s Prime Minister and the Empress Theodora. And they made a lovely
确实，我刚才也在想这个。总之，这就是《恋爱岛》，我们这个时代伟大的电视轰动节目。汤姆，去年我们做了一期以《恋爱岛》为主题的《历史的余味》特别节目。没错。你当时非常喜欢，还想再做一次。好吧，他们每年夏天都会做《恋爱岛》。对。所以如果他们每年夏天都做《恋爱岛》，我们也应该每年夏天都做“历史版恋爱岛”。是的。所以去年的获胜者是斯坦利·鲍德温，你的大英雄，20世纪30年代的首相，以及狄奥多拉皇后。他们组成了一对可爱的
couple. They did. And we should explain to listeners who are not mad. Wondering what the hell is happening here. Yeah, who are not brainless morons. We should explain to these listeners what's going on. And to do that, Tom, we have recruited an absolutely tip-top expert, the same expert who joined us last year, one of Britain's leading Love Island connoisseurs. And that is that is of course would you like to introduce her to the audience yes so this is my daughter katie um who actually introduced me to love island because uh katie and her sister eliza watch it a great deal and talk about it a great deal so that's what inspired last year's historical love island and katie welcome back to the show It is lovely to have you on. And I
情侣。他们确实是。我们应该向那些没疯的听众解释一下。想知道这里到底发生了什么的人。是的，那些不是无脑白痴的人。我们应该向这些听众解释一下发生了什么。为了做到这一点，汤姆，我们请来了一位顶尖专家，就是去年加入我们的那位专家，英国领先的《恋爱岛》鉴赏家之一。那就是，当然，你想向听众介绍她吗？好的，这是我的女儿凯蒂，她实际上把我带入了《恋爱岛》，因为凯蒂和她妹妹伊丽莎经常看这个节目，也经常谈论它，所以这就是去年“历史版恋爱岛”的灵感来源。凯蒂，欢迎回到节目，很高兴你能来。我
wonder, for the benefit of those very few of our listeners who haven't watched Love Island, could you just explain what the rules are, what's going on? Of course. Hello, everyone. Can't believe you've let me come back on. But very, very happy to be here. Yes. So for anyone who hasn't watched Love Island, firstly do it. Secondly, the format is basically that you get four girls and four boys in a villa and the ultimate aim is to find love. And it lasts for about eight weeks. And as you go through the eight weeks, the aim of the game is to stay in a couple. So every single week there's a recoupling and all the islanders have to gather around the fire pit and make a speech about who they want to stay with. And throughout
想，为了那些极少数还没看过《恋爱岛》的听众，你能解释一下规则是什么，发生了什么吗？当然。大家好。真不敢相信你们让我又回来了。但我非常非常高兴能来到这里。是的，所以对于任何还没看过《恋爱岛》的人，首先，去看吧。其次，节目形式基本上是把四个女孩和四个男孩放在一个别墅里，最终目标是找到真爱。节目持续大约八周。在八周的过程中，游戏的目标是保持情侣关系。所以每周都有一次重新配对，所有的岛民都必须聚集在火坑周围，发表关于他们想和谁在一起的演讲。在
the course of the series, the couples are given challenges to test their loyalty to their loved ones. So one of the big challenges is Catherine Moor, where the boys and the girls are split up and four new boys and four new girls are sent in and chaos ensues because most of the boys especially are quite unloyal and the aim of the game at the end is to win and you also get 50k but you also get fame in the UK after you finish so it's quite an interesting experiment in a way because you're seeing whether the people are there to actually find love or are they there to get the Instagram brand deals after they leave. So that's Love Island in a nutshell. Right. It's like the people who come on this podcast, Tom. Are they in it for the right things or are they just hoping to become influencers?
整个系列节目中，情侣们会接受考验，以测试他们对爱人的忠诚度。其中一个大挑战是“爱之屋”（Casa Amor），男孩和女孩会被分开，四名新男孩和四名新女孩会被送进来，混乱随之而来，因为大多数男孩尤其是相当不忠诚的，游戏的最终目标是获胜，你不仅能得到5万英镑，还能在节目结束后在英国获得名气。所以这在某种程度上是一个非常有趣的实验，因为你在观察这些人是为了真正找到爱情，还是为了在离开后获得Instagram的品牌代言。这就是《恋爱岛》的精髓。对。这就像来参加这个播客的人一样，汤姆。他们是为了正确的目标而来，还是只是希望成为网红？
They're in it for the love of learning, Dominic. So what you have done for us, as you did last time, is you have come up with the archetypes, the kind of people that if you watch Love Island, you will see. So four boys, four girls. And what you're going to do is introduce each of these archetypes. And Dominic and I have come up with a figure from history who we think fits that particular archetype. So we will then describe them. And you, at the end of our descriptions of these various characters will decide which of them will pair off exciting i cannot wait for this okay so shall i start with my first male archetype do yeah yeah so the first one i've chosen is the
他们是为了学习的热爱而来，多米尼克。所以你像上次一样，为我们总结了原型，也就是如果你看《恋爱岛》会看到的那种人。四个男孩，四个女孩。你要做的是介绍这些原型中的每一个。多米尼克和我已经想出了一个我们认为符合该原型的历史人物。然后我们会描述他们。在你描述完这些角色后，你将决定他们中谁会配对。太令人兴奋了，我等不及了。好的，那我先从我的第一个男性原型开始？好的，好的，所以我选择的第一个是
jester so this is a classic love island character he is always the center of the pranks and he loves all of the other boys in the villa and often shows way more interest in them than the actual girl he's coupled up with. So he'll often cry whenever someone is dumped, especially one of his boys from the island. He'll cry tears? Yeah, yeah. He'll be very upset. Cracking. But then he'll have slight problems showing the same level of emotion to his partner,
小丑（Jester）。这是一个经典的《恋爱岛》角色，他总是恶作剧的中心，他喜欢别墅里的所有其他男孩，并且往往表现出比他配对的女孩对他们更多的兴趣。所以每当有人被淘汰时，他经常会哭，尤其是当他岛上的兄弟之一被淘汰时。他会流泪？是的，是的。他会非常难过。太棒了。但随后他在向伴侣表达同样程度的情感时会遇到一些困难，
much to her distress. So yes, that's our first one. Okay, so I have chosen King Charles II, who is well known as the Merry Monarch. And a huge part of his merriness is his fondness for japes, for horse racing, for wearing long wigs, for hanging out with the orange sellers and actresses. So he's a tremendous lad. And this is very bad news for his wife, Catherine of Braganza, who comes from Portugal, princess, had been brought up in a convent, very, very pious. And so probably not a natural Love Island contestant. So she's Catholic. Charles II
这让她非常苦恼。所以是的，这是我们的第一个。好的，所以我选择了查理二世，他以“快乐君主”而闻名。他快乐的一大部分原因是他对恶作剧、赛马、戴长假发、与卖橘女和女演员混在一起的喜爱。所以他是个了不起的家伙。这对他的妻子布拉干萨的凯瑟琳来说是个坏消息，她来自葡萄牙，是位公主，在修道院里长大，非常非常虔诚。所以她可能不是天生的《恋爱岛》选手。所以她是天主教徒。查理二世
is a Protestant, ruling a Protestant country. So there's a lot of hostility in Britain to Catherine of Braganza. Charles does stand by her in that sense. He doesn't kind of get rid of her, although there are all kinds of accusations leveled against her, this kind of thing. But basically, he is not going to stay at home and moon around the Queen Catherine of Braganza because he is out there having fun. So his backdrop, of course, is that his dad had his head chopped off. So he's got quite a lot of issues to work through.
是新教徒，统治着一个新教国家。所以英国对布拉干萨的凯瑟琳有很多敌意。查理在某种意义上确实支持她。他没有抛弃她，尽管有各种各样的指控针对她，诸如此类。但基本上，他不会待在家里围着凯瑟琳皇后转，因为他在外面玩得很开心。所以他的背景当然是他父亲被砍了头。所以他有很多问题需要解决。
I mean, it's quite a lot of trauma there. He got exiled because England got taken over by the Commonwealth, by Oliver Cromwell. Charles tried to come back, set himself up as a kind of a popular favorite, try and get people behind him, but they didn't really rally to him. He got defeated in battle. So then he had to escape across England. He hid in an oak tree, very famously. But the great thing that enabled him to escape was his ability to blend in and to mingle and to play. He's kind of a man of the people. So even though he's a King,
我的意思是，那里有很多创伤。他被流放了，因为英格兰被联邦接管了，被奥利弗·克伦威尔接管了。查理试图回来，把自己塑造成一种受欢迎的宠儿，试图让人们支持他，但他们并没有真正团结在他身后。他在战斗中失败了。所以他不得不逃离英格兰。他躲在一棵橡树里，非常出名。但他能够逃脱的伟大之处在于他融入、交往和玩耍的能力。他算是一个平民化的人。所以即使他是个国王，
he has that kind of popular touch. And then when he comes back and he's King, it's been a very do a time under Cromwell. Cromwell's been, you know, banning pies and Christmas, hasn't he? Dominic has banning pies.
他也有那种亲民的特质。然后当他回来成为国王时，在克伦威尔统治下那是一段非常沉闷的时期。克伦威尔一直在，你知道，禁止馅饼和圣诞节，不是吗？多米尼克，禁止馅饼。
That's a bizarre claim. Tom didn't even ban Christmas. No, he didn't. he didn't do any of that so charles comes back from his exile um he is restored this is the restoration cromwell is dead cromwell is not a guy for debauchery charles basically is so he although um he uh he has no children by poor old catherine of braganza he has 12 children by seven mistresses so one of them is Nell Gwynn,
那是个奇怪的说法。汤姆甚至没有禁止圣诞节。不，他没有。他没做过任何那种事。所以查理从流放中回来，他复辟了，这就是复辟时期。克伦威尔死了，克伦威尔不是一个沉溺于放荡的人，查理基本上是。所以尽管他，呃，他与可怜的凯瑟琳没有孩子，但他与七个情妇生了12个孩子。其中一个是内尔·格温，
another is Lady Castlemaine, another is Louise de Quere, who was a Love Island contender in the previous year. Princess Diana was descended from two of his mistresses. The Queen, Camilla, she's descended from one of Charles II's mistresses as well. There's a lot going on there. He loves horse racing. His favorite horse was a horse called Old Roly, and that was the nickname that got given to Charles himself. He loves pranks. He is great friends with a whole succession of notorious rakes, of whom perhaps the most notorious is the Earl of Rochester, a young man, the son of a very devoted follower of Charles II, who had stayed with him throughout all the bad years when Charles was in exile.
另一个是卡斯尔梅恩夫人，另一个是路易丝·德·克鲁阿勒，她是前一年的《恋爱岛》竞争者。戴安娜王妃是他的两个情妇的后裔。卡米拉王后也是查理二世的情妇之一的后裔。那里发生了很多事。他热爱赛马。他最喜欢的马是一匹叫“老罗利”的马，这也是查理本人的绰号。他喜欢恶作剧。他与一连串臭名昭著的浪子是好朋友，其中最臭名昭著的也许是罗切斯特伯爵，一个年轻人，是查理二世一位非常忠诚的追随者的儿子，他在查理流亡的所有糟糕岁月里一直陪伴着他。
So this is Samuel Pepys on Lord Rochester. The king dining yesterday at the Dutch ambassador's. After dinner, they drank and were pretty merry. And among the rest of the king's company, there was that worthy fellow, my Lord of Rochester. And Tom Killigrew, whose mirth and raillery offended the former so much that he did give Tom Killigrew a box on the ear in the king's presence, which do give much offense to the people here at court. So this is very poor form. I mean, even if you're an earl, you don't go up and kind of box people in front of the king. And so Rochester is banned from the court, but Charles II misses him so much that within a few weeks, he's got Rochester back. Then Rochester is spectacularly the court, but Charles II misses him so much that within a few weeks,
所以这是塞缪尔·佩皮斯关于罗切斯特勋爵的记录。国王昨天在荷兰大使家用餐。晚餐后，他们喝酒，玩得很开心。在国王的随从中，有那位值得尊敬的家伙，我的罗切斯特勋爵。还有汤姆·基利格鲁，他的欢笑和嘲弄冒犯了前者，以至于他在国王面前给了汤姆·基利格鲁一个耳光，这在宫廷里引起了很大的冒犯。所以这表现很差。我的意思是，即使你是伯爵，你也不能在国王面前打人。所以罗切斯特被禁止进入宫廷，但查理二世非常想念他，几周之内，他就把罗切斯特找回来了。然后罗切斯特又壮观地……宫廷，但查理二世非常想念他，几周之内，
he's got Rochester back. Then Rochester is spectacularly rude about the king. He writes a poem about him. So this is Rochester on Charles II. Restless he rolls from whore to whore, a merry monarch, scandalous and poor. And so Charles II bans him again, but then forgives him and appoints him the ranger of Woodstock Park. So that's the kind of vibe that's going on with Charles II. There's all this kind of banter. It goes too far. Charles II gets rid of his friends, but then brings them back and makes them rangers of parks. So that's the vibe that's going down. I think he'd be a great contender. He's a good contender, Tom. He's a very good contender.
他就把罗切斯特找回来了。然后罗切斯特又壮观地对国王无礼。他写了一首关于他的诗。所以这是罗切斯特关于查理二世的诗。他不安地从一个妓女滚到另一个妓女，一个快乐的君主，丑闻缠身且贫穷。所以查理二世再次禁止他，但随后原谅了他，并任命他为伍德斯托克公园的护林员。所以这就是查理二世的那种氛围。有各种各样的玩笑。这太过分了。查理二世赶走了他的朋友，但随后又把他们带回来，让他们当公园的护林员。所以这就是正在发生的氛围。我认为他会是一个伟大的竞争者。他是一个很好的竞争者，汤姆。他是一个非常好的竞争者。
I should say, actually, you can dump a fellow Islander if they rub you up the wrong way sometimes. Okay. So if the Earl of Rochester was on the Island and going too far, pushing the pranks too far, Charles would probably get the Earl of Rochester off. And Charles would have to do a speech saying why he's dumping him. He'd say, that poem was too far, Earl of Rochester, you're off. But could he then take it back yes then he can he can come back in a shock twist all right let's have your next one katie
我应该说，实际上，如果岛上的同伴让你感到不舒服，你可以淘汰他们。好的。所以如果罗切斯特伯爵在岛上做得太过分，把恶作剧推得太远，查理可能会把罗切斯特伯爵赶走。查理必须发表讲话说明他为什么要淘汰他。他会说，那首诗太过分了，罗切斯特伯爵，你出局了。但他能收回吗？是的，他可以，他可以在一个令人震惊的转折中让他回来。好的，让我们听听你的下一个，凯蒂。
what's your next archetype has to be a woman this time okay or girl sorry a girl they're not calling women do they uh no no they call them a girl yeah very good dominic so the first girl i have is the minx brilliant so a very vivid character from Love Island. He comes off every year in some kind of form. So she'll come in straight away, couple up with someone, proclaim her love for them in five days. She'll then fall in love
你的下一个原型是什么？这次必须是个女人。好的，或者女孩，抱歉。女孩，他们不叫女人，对吧？呃，不，不，他们叫她们女孩。是的，非常好，多米尼克。所以我有的第一个女孩是“狐狸精”（Minx），太棒了。这是《恋爱岛》中一个非常生动的角色。她每年都会以某种形式出现。所以她会直接进来，和某人配对，在五天内宣布她对他们的爱。然后她会同样快地爱上
equally as quickly as someone else when Castle of Amor comes. So this is when the girls are put into a separate house and new boys come in and they have to test their loyalty. And she'll leave the first boy brokenhearted as well as the girl she has stolen the guy from. So yeah,
另一个人，当“爱之屋”到来时。这就是女孩们被安置在单独的房子里，新男孩进来，她们必须测试她们的忠诚度的时候。她也会让第一个男孩心碎，就像她从那个女孩那里偷走那个男人一样。所以是的，
there's not a lot of loyalty to the ladies. Okay. So I'm choosing the minx and I've chosen Catherine Howard, briefly Queen of England. So she is one of Henry VIII's queens, as you will know, Katie. Catherine Howard was born, we think, in about 1524. And she's kind of been in a Love Island environment before. This is why I think she's such a strong contender. So I had a very good year last year with Theodora and Stanley Baldwin. I was disappointed not to have a good year this time, which is why I've chosen Catherine Howard. Because what happened to Catherine Howard, she's one of the six children of Lord Edmund Howard and Joyce Culpepper. So the Howard thing is really important because she's part of one of the most powerful aristocratic clans in 16th century England, the Howart clan, later to the Duke of Norfolk. And she is brought up at Norfolk House,
对女士们来说没有多少忠诚度。好的。所以我选择了“狐狸精”，我选择了凯瑟琳·霍华德，短暂的英格兰王后。所以她是亨利八世的王后之一，正如你所知，凯蒂。凯瑟琳·霍华德出生于1524年左右。她以前就在《恋爱岛》的环境中待过。这就是为什么我认为她是一个如此强大的竞争者。所以我去年和狄奥多拉以及斯坦利·鲍德温度过了非常美好的一年。这次没能度过美好的一年我很失望，这就是为什么我选择了凯瑟琳·霍华德。因为凯瑟琳·霍华德身上发生了什么，她是埃德蒙·霍华德勋爵和乔伊斯·卡尔佩珀的六个孩子之一。所以霍华德这个姓氏非常重要，因为她是16世纪英格兰最强大的贵族氏族之一，霍华德家族，后来成为诺福克公爵。她在诺福克府长大，
which is in Lambeth, not a million miles from where you are, Tom. Yeah. And Norfolk House, which is the house of her father's stepmother, the Dowager Duchess, Agnes Howart. And this is basically run as a sort of 16th century Love Island arrangement so there are quite a few aristocratic girls who stay there in a kind of dorm Katie and they smuggle boys in at night the girls will steal sweetmeats from the kitchens wine gifts for the blokes so Catherine is absolutely into all this she loves it she likes dancing she likes dogs she
就在兰贝斯，离你所在的地方不远，汤姆。是的。诺福克府，也就是她父亲的继母，道格拉斯公爵夫人艾格尼丝·霍华德的府邸。这基本上是以一种16世纪《恋爱岛》的安排方式运作的，所以有相当多的贵族女孩住在那里，像宿舍一样，凯蒂，她们晚上会偷偷把男孩带进来，女孩们会从厨房偷甜食、酒、给男人的礼物。所以凯瑟琳绝对沉迷于这一切，她喜欢它，她喜欢跳舞，她喜欢狗，她
likes messing around and ugliness and that sort of carry on. Her first liaison is with her music teacher, who's a man called Henry Mannix. And later on at her trial, during her interrogation, I should say, she says, at the flattering and fair persuasions of Mannix, I suffered him at sundry times to handle and touch the secret parts of my body. So this is going on. Anyway, he gets booted out, I think. I think this is discovered. So that's the end of Henry Mannix. And then she starts carrying on with the Dowager Duchess's secretary, Frances Derham. And they call each other husband and wife. They're not husband and
喜欢胡闹和那种行为。她的第一次恋情是和她的音乐老师，一个叫亨利·曼尼克斯的男人。后来在她的审判中，在她的审讯期间，我应该说，她说，在曼尼克斯的奉承和公平劝说下，我多次让他触摸我身体的私密部位。所以这正在发生。总之，他被踢出去了，我想。我想这是被发现了。所以这就是亨利·曼尼克斯的结局。然后她开始和道格拉斯公爵夫人的秘书弗朗西斯·德勒姆鬼混。他们互称丈夫和妻子。他们不是丈夫和
wife. This is very touching. I read he entrusts her with wifely duties, such as looking after his money when he goes away on holiday. So this is quite sweet. But then she meets bloke number three. And now the story takes a darker turn because this is Henry VIII. Now Henry VIII is married to Anne of Cleves, who is not a natural Love Island contestant, it's fair to say at all, because she's German, for one thing. So she's not laugh a minute. She's basically got Angela Merkel's personality.
妻子。这非常感人。我读到他委托她履行妻子的职责，比如在他去度假时照顾他的钱。所以这很甜。但随后她遇到了三号男。现在故事变得更黑暗了，因为这是亨利八世。现在亨利八世娶了安妮·克莱夫斯，她不是天生的《恋爱岛》选手，公平地说，因为她首先是德国人。所以她不是那种很有趣的人。她基本上有安吉拉·默克尔的个性。
And the Howards push young Catherine Howard in front of Henry. They make sure she's sitting near him at parties and things. He thinks she's a brilliant person. He, by the way, at this point, is an elephant of a man and much older. Has his ulcer kicked in? His smelly ulcer?
霍华德家族把年轻的凯瑟琳·霍华德推到了亨利面前。他们确保她坐在派对等场合靠近他。他认为她是一个出色的人。顺便说一句，他此时是一个像大象一样的男人，年纪大得多。他的溃疡发作了吗？他那恶臭的溃疡？
His ulcer has kicked in on his leg. So he's got this stinking ulcer on his leg. But love conquers all, as you know. In the casa amor. So Catherine Howard looks past this. He's delighted by this. She's about 70 years his junior, but that's fine. He says she's the very
他的溃疡在他的腿上发作了。所以他腿上有这个恶臭的溃疡。但爱征服一切，正如你所知。在“爱之屋”里。所以凯瑟琳·霍华德忽略了这一点。他对此感到高兴。她比他小70岁，但这没关系。他说她是
jewel of womanhood. So he boots out Anne of Cleves marries Catherine Howard gives her tons of presents jewels and all this kind of thing. But as you know
女性美的明珠。所以他踢走了安妮·克莱夫斯，娶了凯瑟琳·霍华德，给了她大量的礼物、珠宝和所有这些东西。但正如你所知，
with the minks you know history never stops. No. They go off on a tour of the north but Catherine has eyes
对于“狐狸精”，你知道历史永不停歇。不。他们去北方巡游，但凯瑟琳看中了
for a new a new player who is a man called Thomas Culpepper one of Henry's mates one of his hunting friends Thomas Culpepper has a slightly unsavory past he's been accused of raping a park keeper's wife and then murdering somebody who tried to restrain him or something this wouldn't play well on with Love Island audience well it's very Charles II and Rochester actually Henry was very cross at first but then forgave him said listen he's a great laugh
一个新玩家，一个叫托马斯·卡尔佩珀的男人，亨利的朋友之一，他的狩猎伙伴之一。托马斯·卡尔佩珀有一个稍微不光彩的过去，他被指控强奸了一名公园管理员的妻子，然后谋杀了一个试图制止他的人，或者类似的事情，这在《恋爱岛》观众中不会受欢迎。好吧，这实际上非常像查理二世和罗切斯特。亨利起初非常生气，但随后原谅了他，说听着，他是个很有趣的人，
you know boys will be boys boys will be boys. Boys will be boys. People sometimes overstep the mark. Bring him back. Catherine carries on with Thomas Culpepper during the tour. She smuggles him up to her rooms in Pontefract. Very unromantic place. No offense to people from Pontefract. Great cakes though.
你知道，男孩就是男孩。男孩就是男孩。人们有时会越界。把他带回来。凯瑟琳在巡游期间继续和托马斯·卡尔佩珀鬼混。她把他偷偷带进她在庞特弗拉克的房间。非常不浪漫的地方。对庞特弗拉克的人没有冒犯之意。不过蛋糕很好吃。
Yeah. And a good castle. I think it's Pontefract Castle where, and also the Bishop's Palace in Lincoln, where Culpeper is sneaking up late at night. Anyway, bad news for Catherine Cady. Archbishop Thomas Cranmer leaves Henry, this surely is very Love Island behaviour, he leaves him an anonymous note on his pew in the chapel saying, your wife is cheating on you. Terrible scenes. Henry bursts into floods of tears. He's like a quivering blancmange of misery and regret. Catherine herself, she's arrested. She's in floods of tears. It's absolute scenes. She's taken to the palace at Sion. Henry is very unrelenting, I have to say,
是的。还有一座好城堡。我想是在庞特弗拉克城堡，还有林肯的主教宫，卡尔佩珀深夜溜进去。总之，对凯瑟琳来说是个坏消息，凯蒂。大主教托马斯·克兰默留给亨利一张匿名纸条，这肯定是非常《恋爱岛》的行为，他在教堂的座位上留了一张纸条说，你的妻子在欺骗你。可怕的场景。亨利泪流满面。他像一个颤抖的痛苦和后悔的果冻。凯瑟琳本人，她被捕了。她泪流满面。这绝对是场景。她被带到锡安宫。亨利非常无情，我必须说，
because later on she's dragged onto a barge, again sobbing, taken to the Tower of London, 13th of February, 1542. She is led to the block. Beforehand, she'd been very cool. She'd actually been practicing, laying her head down, practicing for the execution. But when the moment comes, apparently it's terrible scenes. She's pale. She's terrified.
因为后来她被拖上一艘驳船，再次啜泣，被带到伦敦塔，1542年2月13日。她被带到断头台。事先，她一直很冷静。她实际上一直在练习，把头放下来，为处决做练习。但当那一刻到来时，显然场景很可怕。她脸色苍白。她吓坏了。
She's shaking. They have to help her up the steps. And then the blade comes down at the end of her story. And do you want to know what the top historian david loads says about catherine how sympathetically he describes her and her story in his history of the tudors he says she was a stupid and oversexed adolescent a wanton slut who behaved like a whore when did he write that it's about 90 i don't know 1990s or something wow i think his historiography is very different in those days. And her ghost haunts Hampton Court, isn't it?
她在发抖。他们不得不扶她上台阶。然后刀刃落下了，她的故事结束了。你想知道顶级历史学家大卫·洛兹是怎么评价凯瑟琳·霍华德的吗？他在他的《都铎王朝史》中是多么同情地描述她和她的故事？他说她是一个愚蠢且性欲过剩的青少年，一个行为像妓女的放荡荡妇。他是什么时候写的？大约90年代，我不知道，1990年代左右。哇，我想他的史学在那个时代非常不同。她的鬼魂在汉普顿宫出没，不是吗？
I believe so, yeah. You can hear her screams echoing down the corridors. The story is that just after she was outed, after she was discovered, her dancing masters arrived to teach her regular dancing lesson and the doors were closed. And the guard said something like, the days of dancing are over. And they were for Catherine Howard, Katie. Oh gosh. So you can put that right today
我相信是的，是的。你可以听到她的尖叫声在走廊里回荡。故事是，就在她被曝光，被发现后，她的舞蹈老师赶来教她常规的舞蹈课，门关上了。守卫说了一些类似的话，跳舞的日子结束了。对凯瑟琳·霍华德来说确实如此，凯蒂。哦天哪。所以你今天可以纠正这一点，
if you find the right partner for her. Well, yeah, I guess there's the beheading thing to link her and Charles maybe. Yeah, they've both got beheading histories, haven't they, in various ways. Although maybe she wouldn't know she's being beheaded when she's in Love Island. I don't know if they know the whole life journey.
如果你为她找到了合适的伴侣。好吧，是的，我想有斩首的事情可以把她和查理联系起来，也许。是的，他们都有斩首的历史，不是吗，以各种方式。虽然也许她不知道她在《恋爱岛》时会被斩首。我不知道他们是否知道完整的人生旅程。
Well, I mean, she'd be dead if she did. Oh, I see. They don't know what's going to happen to them or what has happened to them. I guess her ghost could come. That's a bit niche, isn't it? A bit niche. I mean, she's sitting there without her head
好吧，我的意思是，如果她知道她就死了。哦，我明白了。他们不知道会发生什么，或者已经发生了什么。我想她的鬼魂可能会来。这有点小众，不是吗？有点小众。我的意思是，她坐在那里，没有头，
round the fire pit. That would be very odd for people. I think we should actually have the next contestant because we're running out of time already. Okay, so I'm going to go back to the men. So this one is the devoted one. This character will most likely pair up with someone like the minx. I don't want to predict, but he will be hurt by her.
围着火坑。这对人们来说会非常奇怪。我认为我们实际上应该进行下一个选手，因为我们已经没时间了。好的，所以我回到男人身上。这个是“奉献者”。这个角色很可能会和像“狐狸精”那样的人配对。我不想预测，但他会被她伤害。
But he's so blinded by love that he is willing to be humiliated over and over again. Okay. So I have nominated Sir William Hamilton, who lived in the 18th century. He served as an MP, and then he became the British ambassador to Naples, to the kingdom of the two Sicilies, as it was called. And to begin with, there would be nothing at all about him that would suggest that he would in any way make a good Love Island contestant. He's an absolute model of sobriety. So he's married to his wife, Catherine, whom he absolutely adores. He's very, very
但他被爱蒙蔽了双眼，以至于他愿意一次又一次地被羞辱。好的。所以我提名了威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，他生活在18世纪。他曾担任议员，后来成为英国驻那不勒斯大使，驻两西西里王国。起初，他身上没有任何东西会表明他会以任何方式成为一个好的《恋爱岛》选手。他是清醒的典范。所以他娶了他的妻子凯瑟琳，他绝对崇拜她。他非常非常
interested in Greek and Roman pottery. So he's hanging out in Naples and of course Pompeii and Herculaneum are nearby. And this is when the excavations there are starting and he becomes a great collector of antiquities. He's very, very interested in volcanoes and earthquakes. He climbs Mount Vesuvius over 70 times. He takes guests up there. One time he takes his friend, the fourth Earl of Bristol, up there and the fourth Earl of Bristol burns his arm on a burning piece of lava. So that's probably the most exciting thing that has happened to him in the course of his life. And also he's a great patron of music. And so he
对希腊和罗马陶器感兴趣。所以他在那不勒斯闲逛，当然庞贝和赫库兰尼姆就在附近。这是那里的挖掘工作开始的时候，他成为了一个伟大的古董收藏家。他非常非常对火山和地震感兴趣。他攀登维苏威火山超过70次。他带客人上去。有一次他带他的朋友，第四代布里斯托尔伯爵上去，第四代布里斯托尔伯爵在燃烧的熔岩上烧伤了手臂。所以这可能是他一生中最令人兴奋的事情。而且他还是音乐的伟大赞助人。所以他
entertains the 14-year-old Mozart in his ambassadorial residence. But as I say, there's nothing there, I think, really that would interest the contestants of Love Island. But then in 1782, his beloved wife Catherine Catherine, dies and Sir William is devastated. I must forever feel the loss of the most amiable, the most gentle and virtuous companion that ever man was blessed with. I mean, very, very touching. And he's very upset. So he goes back home to England to kind of recuperate emotionally.
在官邸招待了14岁的莫扎特。但正如我所说，我认为那里真的没有什么能引起《恋爱岛》选手兴趣的东西。但随后在1782年，他深爱的妻子凯瑟琳去世了，威廉爵士崩溃了。我必须永远感受到失去这位最可爱、最温柔、最贤惠的伴侣的痛苦，这是任何男人都有幸拥有的。我的意思是，非常非常感人。他非常难过。所以他回到英格兰，在情感上恢复一下。
And he stays with his nephew. And his nephew has a very young mistress who'd been born Amy Lyon and she'd worked variously as a housemaid, a dancer, an actress and a courtesan and it is as a courtesan that she is staying with Sir William's nephew and she has taken on the name Emma Hart. This is her kind of stage name. When Sir William meets with Emma, she is 18 years old, and he's an elderly widower, and he's a little bit smitten with her. He goes back to Naples, and he's very, very lonely. After having lived 22 years en famille, it is most terrible to live chiefly alone, he writes to his nephew. The nephew by now is getting a bit bored of Emma Hart. He wants to dump
他和他的侄子住在一起。他的侄子有一个非常年轻的情妇，名叫艾米·里昂，她曾做过女佣、舞者、演员和交际花，正是作为交际花，她和威廉爵士的侄子住在一起，她改名为艾玛·哈特。这是她的艺名。当威廉爵士见到艾玛时，她18岁，他是一位年迈的鳏夫，他有点迷恋她。他回到那不勒斯，他非常非常孤独。在过着22年的家庭生活后，独自生活是最可怕的，他写信给他的侄子。侄子现在对艾玛·哈特有点厌倦了。他想甩掉
her and move on to someone else. So he is very much a Love Island contestant. I mean, he'd be an absolute player. And so he decides, I know, I can see that my uncle, he's quite keen on this young girl. I will fob her off onto him. And so he packs Emma hart off to naples and so william's a bit nonplussed that he's been sent his his nephew's ex-mistress but he's very chivalrous and so he puts her up and indeed her mother who's come with her that's a bit that's a weird detail yeah so that probably doesn't happen in love island people The contestants don't bring their mothers with them, do they? They actually do in the last week, but to kind of see if they approve of their partner. So he puts Emma and her mother up in a palazzo and then he falls increasingly in love. And within five years, he's not only head over heels in love with her, but he's decided he's going to marry her. So they go back to London. They get married there. Emma is now Emma, Lady Hamilton.
她，继续寻找别人。所以他非常像一个《恋爱岛》选手。我的意思是，他绝对是个玩家。所以他决定，我知道，我看得出来我叔叔对这个年轻女孩很感兴趣。我会把她推给他。所以他把艾玛·哈特打发到那不勒斯，威廉爵士有点困惑，因为他被送来了他侄子的前情妇，但他非常绅士，所以他收留了她，实际上还有和她一起来的母亲，那是一个奇怪的细节，是的，所以这可能不会发生在《恋爱岛》中，人们，选手们不会带他们的母亲来，对吧？他们实际上在最后一周会带，看看他们是否认可他们的伴侣。所以他把艾玛和她的母亲安置在一座宫殿里，然后他越来越爱她。五年内，他不仅深深地爱上了她，而且决定要娶她。所以他们回到伦敦。他们在那里结婚。艾玛现在是艾玛，汉密尔顿夫人。
They go back to Naples. Emma Hamilton becomes a great star. So she becomes a huge friend of the Queen of Naples, who is the sister of Marie Antoinette, daughter of Maria Theresa, the Empress of Austria. So this would be very, very Love Island. She does what are called attitudes, which involves her dressing up in kind of wispy classical style swimsuits and doing poses next to the fire pit. So this would be tremendous. But she's not a contestant, he is. No, she becomes very fond of Sir William, who she describes as the best husband and friend. And they seem to be ticking along. But then in 1798, the most famous man in Britain who has just beaten the French fleet at the Battle of the Nile, he sails into town.
他们回到那不勒斯。艾玛·汉密尔顿成为了一颗伟大的明星。所以她成为了那不勒斯王后的好朋友，那是玛丽·安托瓦内特的妹妹，奥地利皇后玛丽亚·特蕾莎的女儿。所以这会非常非常《恋爱岛》。她做所谓的“姿态”，这涉及她穿上那种飘逸的古典风格泳装，在火坑旁摆姿势。所以这会很棒。但她不是选手，他是。不，她变得非常喜欢威廉爵士，她称他为最好的丈夫和朋友。他们似乎相处得很好。但随后在1798年，英国最著名的人，刚刚在尼罗河战役中击败法国舰队的人，他航行进城。
And this is Horatio Nelson. And Emma starts having a fling with him. Everyone's terribly embarrassed on behalf of Sir William, but he puts up with it. He doesn't mind. I think partly because he's so devoted to Emma, and partly because he thinks as British ambassador, it's his duty to allow the hero of the hour, Lord Nelson, to relax any way he wants. If Nelson wants to relax with his wife, then it's his patriotic duty to facilitate that. So 1800, they all return back to England over land, and it's a ménage à trois, and it causes a kind of international scandal. And they arrive in London, and the three of them together take rooms in a hotel. And Nelson is married as well. He hasn't told Lady Nelson that he's back, and he's shacked up with Lady Hamilton and her husband. So Lady Nelson suddenly turns up. They're having dinner. Lady Nelson turns up. Then Nelson's father turns up. They all have dinner. And Lady Nelson observes that Emma is looking a bit larger than she might otherwise be and realizes that Lady Hamilton is pregnant. And Nelson refuses to apologize.
这就是霍拉肖·纳尔逊。艾玛开始和他有了一段恋情。每个人都为威廉爵士感到非常尴尬，但他忍受了。他不介意。我想部分是因为他太爱艾玛了，部分是因为他认为作为英国大使，允许当下的英雄纳尔逊勋爵以他想要的任何方式放松是他的职责。如果纳尔逊想和他的妻子放松，那么促进这一点就是他的爱国职责。所以1800年，他们都陆路回到英格兰，这是一个三人行，引起了一种国际丑闻。他们到达伦敦，他们三个人一起在一家酒店开了房间。纳尔逊也结婚了。他没有告诉纳尔逊夫人他回来了，他和汉密尔顿夫人以及她的丈夫住在一起。所以纳尔逊夫人突然出现了。他们正在吃晚饭。纳尔逊夫人出现了。然后纳尔逊的父亲出现了。他们都吃了晚饭。纳尔逊夫人观察到艾玛看起来比平时大一点，意识到汉密尔顿夫人怀孕了。纳尔逊拒绝道歉。
Basically, there's a massive kind of scandal. It's all over the press. There are cartoons, journalists kind of door-stopping them. They're being papped everywhere they go. It's cartoonists are scribbling. And poor Sir William is a butt of public mockery. He's the most famous cookhold in England. But he still doesn't mind.
基本上，发生了一场巨大的丑闻。到处都是媒体。有漫画，记者在门口堵他们。他们走到哪里都被狗仔队拍。漫画家在涂鸦。可怜的威廉爵士成了公众嘲笑的对象。他是英格兰最著名的戴绿帽者。但他仍然不介意。
He still puts up with it. And Nelson ends up dumping his wife. He goes off to sea, fights the French again. Emma gives birth to their daughter, who they call Horatia, after Horatia, making absolutely clear to everyone who the father is. And Nelson buys a house in Merton. And the three of them go and live there. They go on holiday together. They go on holiday to Wales. They have a beach holiday in Ramsgate. And then in 1803, Sir William collapses and he dies in Emma's arms and he leaves her all his money. Oh, Sir William.
他仍然忍受着。纳尔逊最终甩了他的妻子。他出海了，再次与法国人作战。艾玛生下了他们的女儿，他们叫她霍拉蒂亚，以霍拉肖命名，向所有人明确谁是父亲。纳尔逊在默顿买了一栋房子。他们三个人去那里住。他们一起去度假。他们去威尔士度假。他们在拉姆斯盖特度过了一个海滩假期。然后1803年，威廉爵士倒下了，他在艾玛的怀里去世了，他把所有的钱都留给了她。哦，威廉爵士。
Leaves her 800 pounds. Katie, are you crying? Yeah. He has stuck with her through all this kind of stress. He's put up with the public humiliation of being laughed at, of having cartoons done about him. So I think he is an absolutely model Love Island contestant. Okay. Katie, what's the next contestant, please?
留给她800英镑。凯蒂，你在哭吗？是的。他在这所有的压力中一直坚持着她。他忍受了被嘲笑、被画漫画的公众羞辱。所以我认为他绝对是一个《恋爱岛》选手的典范。好的，凯蒂，下一个选手是谁，请？
Okay. So we're going to go back to the girls. The next one is the resilient one. Okay, brilliant. So quite similar. So she will get rejected over and over again, but she always keeps her head held high. Regally high, would you say?
好的。所以我们要回到女孩身上。下一个是“坚韧者”（Resilient one）。好的，太棒了。所以很相似。所以她会一次又一次地被拒绝，但她总是高昂着头。你会说高贵地高昂着头吗？
Imperially high? Definitely, definitely. Regally high. The public are impressed. Brilliant. They keep her until the final, despite her palpable lack of success in the boy arena. Splendid, splendid.
帝王般地高昂着头？绝对，绝对。高贵地高昂着头。公众印象深刻。太棒了。他们留着她直到决赛，尽管她在男孩竞技场上明显缺乏成功。太棒了，太棒了。
So I have a perfect candidate. She is the Empress Zoe of the Eastern Roman Empire, or the, splendid. So I have a perfect candidate. She is the Empress Zoe of the Eastern Roman Empire or the Byzantine Empire, as people often call it. So Katie, she was born in the year 978 or thereabouts. She's one of the three daughters of the Emperor Constantine VIII. The Byzantine historian Michael Sellus says of her, she was regal in her ways, a woman of great beauty, most imposing in her manner and commanding respect, a woman of passionate interests prepared with equal enthusiasm for both alternatives, death or life. She was open-handed, the sort of woman who could exhaust a sea teeming with gold dust in one day. Her eyes were large, set apart with imposing eyebrows. Her nose was inclined to
所以我有一个完美的人选。她是东罗马帝国，或者，太棒了，佐伊女皇。所以我有一个完美的人选。她是东罗马帝国，或者人们常说的拜占庭帝国的佐伊女皇。所以凯蒂，她出生于978年左右。她是君士坦丁八世皇帝的三个女儿之一。拜占庭历史学家迈克尔·塞勒斯这样评价她，她的方式很高贵，一个拥有巨大美丽的女人，举止非常庄严，令人敬畏，一个拥有热情兴趣的女人，对两种选择——死亡或生命——都准备了同样的热情。她很大方，那种可以在一天内耗尽一片充满金粉的海的女人。她的眼睛很大，分开设置，眉毛令人印象深刻。她的鼻子倾向于
be aquiline and her whole body was radiant with the whiteness of her skin. That may be an issue with all the fake tan. I don't know whether that's a problem. But he also adds, she confused the trifles of the harem with important matters of state, which I think is quite love island. So she has a bit of bad luck, which has a lot of bad luck in her life. She first appears in the history books when her uncle, who's the Emperor Basil II, decides he's going to marry her off to the Holy Roman Emperor Otto III. She's all excited. Everyone says she's a top beauty, really pumped for it. She sets sail from Constantinople. She arrives in Bari to marry Otto III, and she's told he's actually dead. He's died of fever. So miserably, she has to sail back again to Constantinople. And this is a bit of a
鹰钩鼻，她的整个身体散发着她皮肤的洁白。这可能是一个问题，因为所有的假晒黑。我不知道这是否是个问题。但他还补充说，她把后宫的琐事与国家大事混为一谈，我认为这很《恋爱岛》。所以她运气有点不好，她一生中运气很不好。她第一次出现在历史书中时，她的叔叔，也就是巴西尔二世皇帝，决定把她嫁给神圣罗马帝国皇帝奥托三世。她很兴奋。每个人都说她是顶级美女，真的很期待。她从君士坦丁堡启航。她到达巴里嫁给奥托三世，却被告知他实际上死了。他死于发烧。所以可怜地，她不得不再次航行回君士坦丁堡。这有点
blow for her, Katie, because she spends the next 27 years effectively locked up in the palace, stuck in her apartments. So that's very boring. But then her time comes at last. Her father, Constantine, dies of old age. And she is basically the next person standing, but she needs to marry to become empress. And her father has already arranged a marriage for her with an old man who's the governor of Constantinople, who's called Romanus Argyris, who becomes Romanus III. Now, he's this sort of wizened old bloke. She has no interest in him at all. She becomes infatuated with a young courtier called Michael the Paphlagonian, and she starts an affair with Michael.
打击，凯蒂，因为她在接下来的27年里实际上被锁在宫殿里，困在她的公寓里。所以这很无聊。但随后她的时间终于到了。她的父亲君士坦丁因年老去世了。她基本上是下一个站着的人，但她需要结婚才能成为女皇。她的父亲已经为她安排了一场婚姻，嫁给一个老人，他是君士坦丁堡的总督，叫罗曼努斯·阿吉里斯，他成为了罗曼努斯三世。现在，他是那种干瘪的老家伙。她对他一点兴趣都没有。她迷恋上了一个叫迈克尔·帕夫拉戈尼亚的年轻朝臣，她开始和迈克尔有染。
Romanus, he's a bit of a William Hamilton type, because he allows Michael to become his personal kind of attendant. But she and her husband fall out, so she basically gets Michael to murder him. The emperor is drowned in his bath. That's very extreme Love Island behavior. And Michael becomes the emperor. But, but, Katie, how does he reward her? He banishes her to the women's apartments again, where she'd been for 27 years.
罗曼努斯，他有点像威廉·汉密尔顿类型，因为他允许迈克尔成为他的私人随从。但她和她的丈夫闹翻了，所以她基本上让迈克尔谋杀了。皇帝在浴缸里淹死了。这非常极端的《恋爱岛》行为。迈克尔成为了皇帝。但是，但是，凯蒂，他怎么回报她？他再次把她流放到妇女公寓，她在那里待了27年。
No. I was only going out with you because, you know, for the Instagram clicks or whatever. Yeah. So was it fake grafting, Dominic? It was fake grafting, as I believe they call it on the island. But he, fate turns against him or the audience turn against him. He's epileptic and this gets worse and worse. He gets dropsy, edema.
不。我只是因为，你知道，为了Instagram的点击量什么的才和你出去。是的，所以那是虚假的“嫁接”，多米尼克？那是虚假的“嫁接”，我相信他们在岛上是这样称呼的。但他，命运对他不利，或者观众对他不利。他患有癫痫，这变得越来越严重。他患有水肿，水肿。
He swells up like a balloon with water and his legs become gangrenous. His legs become gangrenous and he dies. She's still hanging around though. She reemerges from the palace. She says, I need another emperor. She adopts his nephew, who's also called Michael, right? So this is Michael V. At this point his nephew, who's also called Michael. Right. So this is Michael V.
他像气球一样肿胀，腿变得坏疽。他的腿变得坏疽，他死了。她还在附近徘徊。她从宫殿里重新出现。她说，我需要另一个皇帝。她收养了他的侄子，也叫迈克尔，对吧？所以这是迈克尔五世。此时他的侄子，也叫迈克尔。对。所以这是迈克尔五世。
At this point, Katie, he also turns on her. Oh, no. He tries to banish her to a monastery on the Prince's Island in the Sea of Marmara. But the audience by now, they admire her resilience. Yeah. She's become a bit of a favorite. Yeah. So the audience, I mean, they literally riot.
此时，凯蒂，他也背叛了她。哦，不。他试图把她流放到马尔马拉海王子岛的一座修道院。但观众现在钦佩她的韧性。是的。她已经成为了一点宠儿。是的。所以观众，我的意思是，他们真的暴动了。
People tearing through the streets. Michael goes and hides in a church. I don't know how much churchgoing takes place on Love Island, but he's not the contestant, she is. He's dragged out of the church and he's blinded by her chief sort of captain of the guard, who's a man from the north called Harold Hardrada. So he gouges Michael's eyes out. That's the end of Michael.
人们在街上撕扯。迈克尔去躲在教堂里。我不知道《恋爱岛》上有多少教堂活动，但他不是选手，她是。他被从教堂拖出来，被她的首席卫队长弄瞎了，那是一个来自北方的人，叫哈拉尔德·哈德拉达。所以他挖出了迈克尔的眼睛。这就是迈克尔的结局。
She needs another husband now. She's had a lot of bad luck she needs another husband the bad news is she's now 64 the good news is that Byzantine historian Michael Sellers says every part of her was firm and in good condition so she'd still look good in a swimsuit exactly exactly
她现在需要另一个丈夫。她运气很不好，她需要另一个丈夫。坏消息是她现在64岁了，好消息是拜占庭历史学家迈克尔·塞勒斯说她身体的每个部分都很结实，状况良好，所以她穿泳装看起来仍然很好，完全，完全
so she's still Katie don't be ageist we're not ageist on the rest of history no no it's just the description from the historian different times that's journalist for you
所以她仍然，凯蒂，不要有年龄歧视，我们在《历史的余味》中没有年龄歧视，不，不，这只是历史学家的描述，不同的时代，这就是记者为你做的
yeah it's journalist exactly so she now marries somebody called Constantine Monomachus he is about her age thank God and he's a former
是的，这正是记者，所以她现在嫁给了一个叫君士坦丁·莫诺马库斯的人，他大约和她同龄，感谢上帝，他是一个前任
ladies man he's very loose he's very urbane I imagine him as Charles Dance crazy name crazy guy so she marries him but there's bad news constantine monomachus brings with him his mistress no maria sclerina who lives with them in the palace who's a raven haired beauty and um for
他是个花花公子，非常随性，也非常风流，我把他想象成查尔斯·丹斯，名字很疯狂，人也很疯狂，所以她嫁给了他，但有个坏消息，君士坦丁·莫诺马库斯带来了他的情妇，也就是玛丽亚·斯克莱里纳，她和他们一起住在宫殿里，那是一位黑发美女，而且嗯……
poor old um zoe i think this is a little bit humiliating and so she dies in 1050 she's lived to a ripe old age so she's lived to mid-70s but she's never really i mean she's never been not she's been knocked down again and again but she's always dragged herself back up and she's very much a crowd favorite they will riot and gouge out your eyes if you cross zoe and the thing is dominic that byzantine empresses have a track record in Love Island, don't they? Well, Theodora won.
可怜的佐伊，我觉得这有点丢人，所以她在1050年去世了，她活到了高龄，也就是70多岁，但她从来没有……我是说，她从未真正……她一次又一次地被打倒，但她总是能把自己拉起来，而且她非常受大众欢迎，如果你惹恼了佐伊，他们会暴动并挖出你的眼睛，多米尼克，拜占庭皇后在《恋爱岛》上可是有前科的，不是吗？嗯，西奥多拉赢了。
Yeah. I would imagine that Zoe is very conscious of that. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. That one of her predecessors had won Love Island. I think as well that business about being firm and in good condition is a real... When I saw that, I thought, you know... Yeah.
是的，我想佐伊对此非常清楚，是的，是的，她的一位前任赢得了《恋爱岛》，我也认为关于保持坚定和良好状态的那件事是一个真正的……当我看到那个时，我想，你知道……是的。
She's a contender. She's a definite contender. The viewing audience would be impressed by that backstory. Anyway, I don't want to prejudge what you're going to decide, Katie. I don't want to put pressure on you. She's my favourite. You know who I think would be good for her would be Sir William. Are the public ready for two quite elderly winners, Tom?
她是一个竞争者，绝对是一个竞争者，观众会对那段背景故事印象深刻，总之，凯蒂，我不想预判你的决定，我不想给你压力，她是我的最爱，你知道我认为谁适合她吗？威廉爵士，汤姆，公众准备好迎接两位相当年长的获胜者了吗？
I think they are. I think they are. Well, time will tell. Yeah. Because we have to take a break, don't we? So what sort of adverts do they have in Love Island, Katie? eBay is the sponsor this year. Oh, crikey. We're not in that league, Tom.
我想他们准备好了，我想他们准备好了，嗯，时间会证明一切，是的，因为我们得休息一下，不是吗？那么凯蒂，他们在《恋爱岛》里有什么样的广告？eBay是今年的赞助商，哦，天哪，我们不在那个级别，汤姆。
No. Sadly, we're more flights to Las Vegas, aren't we? Which is very Love Island in its own way. All right. We'll take a break now and we'll return for more contestants. See you in a second. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. See you in a second. access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
不，遗憾的是，我们更多是去拉斯维加斯的航班，不是吗？这在某种程度上非常《恋爱岛》，好了，我们现在休息一下，回来后会有更多的参赛者，一会儿见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，一会儿见，获取现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com，就是therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are on Love Island. What was that review entitled? Brainless Morons. Woohoo! No, I think the four contenders we've had, well, maybe three of them, are clearly very smart. I don't think Catherine Howard is quite as smart as she might have been, but the other three.
欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》，我们正在谈论《恋爱岛》，那个评论的标题是什么？《无脑白痴》，呜呼！不，我认为我们拥有的四位竞争者，好吧，也许其中三位，显然非常聪明，我不认为凯瑟琳·霍华德像她可能表现出的那样聪明，但另外三位……
Okay, so you're back on, Tom. Katie, what's your next archetype? The next one is the power-hungry one. So this lady has applied for Love Island every single year, hoping to get her big break and become the new Molly May, who is one of the most commercially successful contestants of UK Love Island ever so commercially she's had lots of kind of brand endorsements yeah she's worth I think five million now so she will cause arguments with the other girls and pick them on purpose to get as much airtime as possible the public sees straight through it but they are conflicted she's very likable, but she also brings the drama.
好吧，汤姆，轮到你了，凯蒂，你的下一个原型是什么？下一个是渴望权力的人，所以这位女士每年都申请《恋爱岛》，希望能获得重大突破，成为新的莫莉·梅，她是英国《恋爱岛》有史以来商业上最成功的参赛者之一，所以在商业上她得到了很多品牌代言，是的，我想她现在身价五百万，所以她会故意和其他女孩争吵并挑衅她们，以获得尽可能多的出镜时间，公众一眼就能看穿，但他们很矛盾，她非常讨人喜欢，但她也带来了戏剧性。
Okay, so Dominic has already chosen one Roman empress in the form of Zoe. I'm choosing another one. And this is the wife of the Emperor Nero, his great beloved, Poppaea Sabina. And she was the most fashionable woman in Rome. Incredible beauty, unbelievably stylish, had kind of amber hair. Nero would send to Denmark for amber and then he would decorate his palace with it as a tribute to her. She actually had her own brands of cosmetics, which were, people wanted to look like her. She would bathe in asses milk to protect her complexion. Her mules, when she went out on trips carrying her luggage,
好吧，多米尼克已经选择了佐伊作为罗马皇后，我选择了另一位，她是尼禄皇帝的妻子，他挚爱的人，波培娅·萨宾娜，她是罗马最时髦的女人，美得不可思议，极其时尚，有着琥珀色的头发，尼禄会派人去丹麦寻找琥珀，然后用它装饰他的宫殿作为对她的致敬，她实际上有自己的化妆品品牌，人们都想看起来像她，她会用驴奶洗澡来保护她的肤色，当她外出旅行携带行李时，她的骡子……
they would all be shod with gold. So she is absolutely the cutting edge of fashion and she'd be an amazing, amazing influencer. Every sponsor would want her, I think, advertising their products. But she is a bit of a baggage. I mean, she is a bit of a piece of work. And I think that that may be because she had quite a tough upbringing. She was the daughter of a guy called Titus Olius. And so originally she was called Olia, but then he gets caught up in a kind of court scandal and gets ruined. And so she then takes the name of her mother, who was also called Poppaea Sabina. But then Poppaea Sabina gets forced to commit suicide by the Empress Messalina, who's a love rival. So
它们都会钉上金蹄铁，所以她绝对是时尚的最前沿，她会是一个了不起的网红，我想每个赞助商都会想要她来宣传他们的产品，但她有点麻烦，我是说，她是个很难对付的人，我认为这可能是因为她成长过程很艰难，她是提图斯·奥利乌斯女儿，所以最初她叫奥莉娅，但后来他卷入了一场宫廷丑闻并被毁了，所以她改用了她母亲的名字，她母亲也叫波培娅·萨宾娜，但后来波培娅·萨宾娜被情敌梅萨利娜皇后逼迫自杀，所以……
Papaya Sabina absolutely has a sense of how high the stakes can be on Love Island, that you really have to play it hard. So Papaya, both her parents have been ruined. One of them has been disgraced. The other one has been forced to commit suicide. And so she's looking for a partner who can help her get a leg up in this competitive world of influencing in, uh, Julia, Claudia and Rome. So she marries the head of, of the Praetorian guard. So you'd think he'd be a banker, uh, but then he gets removed. So that's no good. So she dumps him. Um, and she moves on to a guy who was the best friend of Nero, a man called Otho, who again is very, very stylish, wears a cutting edge toupee, depilates his legs.
波培娅·萨宾娜绝对知道《恋爱岛》上的赌注有多高，你真的必须全力以赴，所以波培娅，她的父母都被毁了，其中一个名誉扫地，另一个被迫自杀，所以她正在寻找一个能帮助她在朱里亚-克劳狄王朝罗马这个竞争激烈的网红世界中获得提升的伴侣，所以她嫁给了禁卫军首领，你可能会认为他是个银行家，但后来他被撤职了，所以那没用，于是她甩了他，然后她转向了一个尼禄的好友，一个叫奥托的人，他同样非常非常时尚，戴着前卫的假发，给腿部脱毛。
So he's kind of literally very, very smooth. And then a bit like with Nelson and Hamilton and Emma, they all get involved in a main achertoire. And the gossip columnists are obsessed by this. So there are lots of different interpretations in the press about what's going on. So maybe Otho had boasted to Nero too much about how sexy his wife was and Nero's kind of moved in. Or maybe they're having a threesome and then Nero decides that he wants Papaya for himself or whatever, who knows what's going on. But basically
所以他从字面上看非常非常圆滑，然后有点像纳尔逊、汉密尔顿和艾玛，他们都卷入了一场三角恋，八卦专栏作家对此非常着迷，所以媒体对正在发生的事情有很多不同的解读，也许奥托向尼禄吹嘘了太多关于他妻子有多性感的事，尼禄插足了，或者他们正在玩三人行，然后尼禄决定他想要波培娅，谁知道发生了什么，但基本上……
Nero decides that he's going to marry Papaya for himself. And so he sends Otho off to govern Portugal. But there is a problem that Nero is already married to his stepsister, Octavia. And so Poppaea is saying, I'm not just going to be your mistress. I want to be the empress. I want to marry you. So poor Octavia, Nero is now obsessed with Poppaea Sabina. And so he accuses her of committing adultery, which is absolutely shameless because Nero has been committing adultery left, right and center. Octavia gets sent off to a remote island off Italy and then Papaya Sabina demands that she be executed. So Nero is so smitten by this point that he sends a guard to go and chop her head off
尼禄决定他要娶波培娅，所以他把奥托派去管理葡萄牙，但有个问题，尼禄已经娶了他的继妹屋大维娅，所以波培娅说，我不仅仅要做你的情妇，我想成为皇后，我想嫁给你，所以可怜的屋大维娅，尼禄现在迷上了波培娅·萨宾娜，于是他指控她通奸，这绝对是无耻的，因为尼禄一直在到处通奸，屋大维娅被送到了意大利外的一个偏远岛屿，然后波培娅·萨宾娜要求处决她，所以尼禄此时此刻被迷住了，他派了一名卫兵去砍下她的头……
and brings Octavia's head back. They're from revolts, don't they? They do. Yes, they do. As you say, Papaya Sabina is quite unlikable and Octavia, people in Rome feel very sympathetic about her, but that doesn't stop Papaya because she knows that the key is to get off with the emperor. So Octavia ends up dead. Her head is brought back to Papaya and Papaya keeps it as a kind of souvenir. So she's quite tough.
并带回了屋大维娅的头，它们来自叛乱，不是吗？是的，确实如此，正如你所说，波培娅·萨宾娜相当令人讨厌，而罗马人对屋大维娅非常同情，但这并没有阻止波培娅，因为她知道关键是和皇帝搞好关系，所以屋大维娅最终死了，她的头被带回给波培娅，波培娅把它当作一种纪念品，所以她相当强硬。
Yeah. She's very good at the brands. I think she'd be an absolute player on Love Island. Yeah. I don't think you'd want to come up against her. Nothing will stop her from getting the donkey milk brand deals after she leaves. Exactly. Yeah.
是的，她非常擅长品牌营销，我想她会是《恋爱岛》上的绝对玩家，是的，我想你不会想和她作对，没有什么能阻止她在离开后获得驴奶的品牌交易，没错，是的。
Exactly. And she ends up dead because Nero ends up kicking her to death. So it all turns out badly yeah I can see her and Emperor Zoe her and Emperor Zoe having some serious clashes they'd have some real beef
没错，她最终死了，因为尼禄最终把她踢死了，所以结果很糟糕，是的，我能看到她和佐伊皇后发生严重的冲突，他们会有真正的矛盾……
wouldn't they they would and I think I'd probably back Papaya but you what Zoe's never beaten Tom well we'll see I mean she doesn't get
不是吗？他们会的，我想我可能会支持波培娅，但你认为佐伊从未被打败过，汤姆，好吧，我们走着瞧，我是说她没有……
a head cut off or kicked to death or any of these things by Nero by her own husband that never happened to Zoe Zoe made sure her husband died first.
被砍头或被踢死，或者被尼禄，被她自己的丈夫做这些事，这从未发生在佐伊身上，佐伊确保了她的丈夫先死。
Yeah, but Pepea has a glamorous ending. That's much more Love Island. She's a loser, though. She's a loser. Also, Pepea, I guess, could say, look what I did to Octavia. You'll be next if you cross me. Yeah, but Zoe wasn't next. She never was.
是的，但波培娅有一个迷人的结局，那更像《恋爱岛》，不过她是个失败者，她是个失败者，而且波培娅，我想可以说，看看我对屋大维娅做了什么，如果你惹我，你就是下一个，是的，但佐伊不是下一个，她从来都不是。
Anyway, this is all part of the excitement of it. But we need some more contestants. So who's next, Katie? Okay, I'll go to a boy. So the next one I'm going to do is the other jester yeah this guy will be a duo with charles ii and he is much loved by the public and deeply in love with his lady but repeatedly stung by her will go on to become a very much loved presenter of shows on channel four like nick knowles or somebody like that yeah isn't
总之，这都是兴奋的一部分，但我们需要更多的参赛者，那么下一个是谁，凯蒂？好的，我选一个男孩，下一个我要选的是另一个小丑，是的，这家伙会和查理二世组成二人组，他深受公众喜爱，深爱着他的女士，但却屡次被她伤害，他后来会成为像尼克·诺尔斯那样深受喜爱的第四频道节目主持人，是的，不是吗……
he a presenter of uh things on channel four anyway listen my choice is uh somebody who would definitely get on well with charles ii it's um russian czar peter the great so peter the great was born in 1672 katie um the key thing you need to know about him is he's six foot eight he's a massive bloke he's incredibly imposing he's a real roister dodoister. He loves his dwarves, doesn't he? He loves dwarves. We'll get onto the dwarves. He expands the frontiers of Russia enormously, beats the Swedes, who were previously their big rivals in the Baltic. He builds a Russian navy. He leads a kind of cultural revolution. He's a man of the early enlightenment. He wants to transform Russia into this great sort of modern powerhouse, but he's a man who knows how to party, loves pranks, loves partying.
他是第四频道节目的主持人，总之，听着，我的选择是……一个肯定会和查理二世相处得很好的人，他是俄罗斯沙皇彼得大帝，所以彼得大帝出生于1672年，凯蒂，关于他你需要知道的关键是，他身高6英尺8英寸，是个大块头，非常有威严，他是个真正的狂欢者，他喜欢他的侏儒，不是吗？他喜欢侏儒，我们会谈到侏儒，他极大地扩展了俄罗斯的边界，击败了瑞典人，他们以前是波罗的海的大对手，他建立了一支俄罗斯海军，他领导了一场文化革命，他是早期启蒙运动的人，他想把俄罗斯变成一个伟大的现代强国，但他是一个懂得如何聚会、喜欢恶作剧、喜欢聚会的人。
So in 1698, he launches what he calls his Grand Embassy. He travels, often incognito, around Western Europe with a load of attendants to try and observe what's going on so that he can modernize Russia. He arrives in England. He's in England for about four months. I don't know whether he would bring these people to the island. It's very unclear because obviously he's never been on Love Island before. He traveled with four chamberlains, two clocksmiths, three interpreters, a cook, a priest, six trumpeters, 70 soldiers, all as tall as him, four dwarves and a monkey. So he pitches up in England. He stays at the diarist John
所以1698年，他发起了他所谓的“大出使”，他经常隐姓埋名，带着一大群随从在西欧旅行，试图观察正在发生的事情，以便他能使俄罗斯现代化，他到达了英国，他在英国待了大约四个月，我不知道他是否会把这些人带到岛上，这很不清楚，因为显然他以前从未参加过《恋爱岛》，他带着四名侍从、两名钟表匠、三名翻译、一名厨师、一名牧师、六名小号手、70名和他一样高的士兵、四名侏儒和一只猴子，所以他来到英国，住在日记作者约翰……
Evelyn's house in Deptford. And Tom, we discussed this before in The Rest is History. When he moves out, Christopher Wren is sent round to sort of tally up the damage. They have caused £300 worth of damage, including £3 for wheelbarrows broken by the Tsar in races and parties and such. All the floors are covered with ink. All the curtains and the bedclothes have been torn to pieces. All the chairs have been smashed. 300 window panes have been broken. The garden has been torn up. And this is just in the course of their kind of roistering. He had a mistress, an actress called Letitia Cross. When he left England, he said, here's 500 pounds, which is the equivalent of
伊夫林在德特福德的房子里，汤姆，我们之前在《剩下的就是历史》中讨论过这个，当他搬走时，克里斯托弗·雷恩被派去清点损失，他们造成了价值300英镑的损失，包括沙皇在比赛和聚会中弄坏手推车造成的3英镑，所有的地板都沾满了墨水，所有的窗帘和床单都被撕成了碎片，所有的椅子都被砸碎了，300块窗户玻璃被打破了，花园被翻了个底朝天，而这仅仅是在他们狂欢的过程中，他有一个情妇，一个叫莱蒂西亚·克罗斯的女演员，当他离开英国时，他说，这是500英镑，相当于……
more than a million pounds today. She was absolutely gutted by this. She said, I'm worth a lot more than this. And he said, frankly, I think I'm being very generous. I think you're overpaid given the nature of your services. He goes back to Russia. Anyway, as Tom said, he's massively into dwarves. He stages a wedding for his favorite dwarf in 1710. He orders that all dwarves in Russia be brought to St. Petersburg. He forces them to drink goblets of vodka and dance until they fall over. He regularly convenes what he calls the all-drunken synod of prostitutes, dwarves, and other characters. And he tells each person at this party, this all-drunken synod, your name is going to be Archdeacon Thrust the Prick,
今天超过一百万英镑，她对此感到非常沮丧，她说，我远不止这个价值，他说，坦率地说，我认为我已经非常慷慨了，考虑到你服务的性质，我认为你被高估了，他回到俄罗斯，总之，正如汤姆所说，他非常迷恋侏儒，他在1710年为他最喜欢的侏儒举办了一场婚礼，他下令将俄罗斯所有的侏儒都带到圣彼得堡，他强迫他们喝伏特加酒杯并跳舞直到摔倒，他定期召集他所谓的“全醉主教会议”，由妓女、侏儒和其他角色组成，他告诉这个聚会上的每个人，这个全醉主教会议，你的名字将是“推刺大祭司”，
or you're going to be called Archdeacon F-Off, or any of these kind of things. So that's all great fun. He's a great lad. He's a great roisterer. Now, the obvious issue is what about his love life? He's deeply in love with this lady, but repeatedly stung by her. So he's married twice.
或者你会被称为“滚蛋大祭司”，或者任何这类名字，所以这很有趣，他是个很棒的小伙子，他是个很棒的狂欢者，现在，显而易见的问题是他的爱情生活怎么样？他深爱着这位女士，但却屡次被她伤害，所以他结过两次婚。
His first wife is called Eudokia. They had an arranged marriage, but they fell out. And Peter exiled her to a convent in Susdal. And he thought, she'll go and she'll be an icon and that'll be lovely. But no, she starts an affair with an officer called Stepan Glebov. And I think it's a sign of what a lovely fellow Peter is, how much he's hurt by this, that he's so upset that he has Stepan Glebov impaled on a stake. Because that would be an incredible adornment to Love Island. And the stake, we read, was artfully inserted to miss all the vital organs so that Stepan
他的第一任妻子叫叶多基娅，他们是包办婚姻，但他们闹翻了，彼得把她流放到苏兹达尔的一座修道院，他想，她会去那里，成为一个偶像，那会很可爱，但没有，她开始和一个叫斯捷潘·格列博夫的军官有染，我认为彼得是个多么可爱的人，他对此感到多么受伤，这是一个标志，他非常心烦意乱，以至于他让斯捷潘·格列博夫被钉在木桩上，因为那将是对《恋爱岛》的一个不可思议的装饰，而且我们读到，木桩被巧妙地插入，避开了所有重要器官，以便斯捷潘……
would live longer. And then Peter is so hurt that he gets his soldiers to force Eudokia to watch Stepan's death agonies. How long did it last? Oh, probably hours and hours and hours, maybe days. So that's that. He also has a bit of bad luck. He has a Scottish mistress called Mary Hamilton, but it turns out that she's been stealing
能活得更久，然后彼得非常受伤，以至于他让他的士兵强迫叶多基娅观看斯捷潘死亡的痛苦，持续了多久？哦，可能几个小时又几个小时，也许几天，所以就是这样，他也有点倒霉，他有一个叫玛丽·汉密尔顿的苏格兰情妇，但事实证明她一直在偷……
from his second wife, the Empress Catherine. So again, Peter is very, very hurt and he has her beheaded. But then in a sign of his son foi, his call and composure, which I think would strongly advantage him on the island, he goes up and he picks up her head and he shows it to the crowd and he gives them a lesson on anatomy, pointing to the head. So it says, he pointed out the sliced vertebrae, open windpipe and dripping arteries before kissing the bloody lips and dropping the head. So again, that's a bit gruesome. Yeah. A lot of listeners will say Peter the Great sounds like a terrible man. So to make them feel better and to curry favour with that element of
他第二任妻子凯瑟琳皇后的东西，所以彼得再次感到非常非常受伤，他让她被斩首，但随后，作为一个他冷静沉着的标志，我认为这会极大地对他有利，他走上前，捡起她的头，向人群展示，并给他们上了一堂解剖课，指着头，所以它说，他指出了切开的椎骨、打开的气管和滴血的动脉，然后亲吻了血淋淋的嘴唇并扔掉了头，所以再次，这有点可怕，是的，很多听众会说彼得大帝听起来是个可怕的人，所以为了让他们感觉好一点并讨好我们观众的那一部分……
our audience, I will say the good news is he died of hideous bladder problems. So at the end of his life, surgeons managed to extract two litres of blocked urine from his gangrenous bladder, and he dies of a gangrenous bladder a year later. So he's quite a character. In fact, Tom, we're going to return to Peter the Great next year on the rest is history, a little series on Peter the Great and the Great Northern War. What kind of Channel 4 series do you think he'd end up presenting? Don't they do things like naked bodies? Naked bodies, I was going to say.
我会说好消息是他死于可怕的膀胱问题，所以在他生命的尽头，外科医生设法从他坏死的膀胱中取出了两升堵塞的尿液，一年后他死于坏死性膀胱炎，所以他是个很有个性的人，事实上，汤姆，明年我们将在《剩下的就是历史》中回到彼得大帝，做一个关于彼得大帝和大北方战争的小系列，你认为他最终会主持什么样的第四频道系列节目？他们不是做那种裸体之类的吗？裸体，我正要说。
Yeah. He would do that with naked severed heads or whatever, wouldn't he? There's a lot of severed heads in this villa. That would be the bonding point. That's history. That's history, Katie. Yeah. Severed heads and impaled bodies
是的，他会带着裸露的断头之类的做那个，不是吗？这个别墅里有很多断头，那将是结合点，那是历史，那是历史，凯蒂，是的，断头和被钉在木桩上的尸体……
and impaled bodies that can be their icebreaker at the beginning of the season I'm not going to prejudge anything again I don't want to influence you Katie but I think he'd get on
和被钉在木桩上的尸体，那可以作为他们本季开始时的破冰船，我不会再预判任何事情，我不想影响你，凯蒂，但我认为他会相处得……
brilliantly with Zoe ooh why do you think he'd get on with Zoe they're both the emperor and empress we can't get into discussion now we've got
非常出色，和佐伊，哦，为什么你认为他会和佐伊相处得很好？他们都是皇帝和皇后，我们现在不能讨论了，我们有……
she had people's eyes gouged out Dominic stop stop it we've got to get on alright Tom it's on it's your go okay this is my last girl the last girl is the out of place one so she works in a crazy job like a landmine disposal and agrees to go on love island because she thinks it would be a great platform for the social cause she believes in and that it will push her out of her comfort zone. And in a nice twist of fate, she actually ends up falling in love. So I have chosen Mary Fisher, who was a housemaid,
她让人挖出了别人的眼睛，多米尼克，停下，停下，我们得继续，好吧，汤姆，轮到你了，好的，这是我的最后一个女孩，最后一个女孩是格格不入的那一个，所以她在做一份疯狂的工作，比如地雷清理，并同意去《恋爱岛》，因为她认为这将是一个很好的平台，可以宣传她所信仰的社会事业，并且这会把她推向舒适区之外，在一个命运的巧合中，她最终坠入了爱河，所以我选择了玛丽·费舍尔，她是一名女佣，
lived in Yorkshire in the 17th century. She was born in 1628. But then in 1651, she is serving at table and she hears this guy called George Fox preach a sermon. And George Fox is a founder of a group called Quakers. And Quakers, the spirit of the Lord descends on them, and they start shaking and trembling and roaring and crying and foaming at the mouth. And this is why they get called Quakers. And Mary Fisher decides that this is great. She's going to sign up to it. Quakers believe in absolute human equality.
17世纪住在约克郡，她出生于1628年，但在1651年，她在餐桌旁服务，听到一个叫乔治·福克斯的人布道，乔治·福克斯是一个叫贵格会团体的创始人，而贵格会，主的灵降临在他们身上，他们开始颤抖、战栗、咆哮、哭泣并口吐白沫，这就是他们被称为“贵格会”的原因，玛丽·费舍尔决定这太棒了，她要加入，贵格会相信绝对的人类平等。
They believe in gender equality. They believe in giving away all their earthly possessions. And this really appeals to Mary. So she becomes a Quaker. And I think that you might think that going around the world preaching about the spirit of the Lord might not be entirely Love Island behavior, except for the fact that Quakers are quite prone to making public statements by taking all their clothes off and walking around naked. That might be something that the viewers of
他们相信性别平等，他们相信放弃所有世俗财产，这真的很吸引玛丽，所以她成为了贵格会教徒，我想你可能会认为环游世界宣扬主的灵可能不完全是《恋爱岛》的行为，除了贵格会非常倾向于通过脱掉所有衣服并赤身裸体走动来发表公开声明，那可能是《恋爱岛》的观众……
Love Island would enjoy in Mary's case. She has quite a tough life because she is absolutely committed to spreading the good news of Quakerism. So she goes to Cambridge where she protests against the students who are all being trained to become vicars. Quakers don't really approve of vicars. And because of this, she gets taken to the market cross and flogged. And she is the first female Quaker to be publicly whipped for her Quaker ministry. Then she goes off to America. She goes to Barbados, where she manages to convert the governor
在玛丽的情况下会喜欢的，她生活相当艰难，因为她绝对致力于传播贵格会的福音，所以她去了剑桥，在那里她抗议那些正在接受培训成为牧师的学生，贵格会不太赞成牧师，因为这个，她被带到市场十字路口并被鞭打，她是第一个因贵格会事工而被公开鞭打的女性贵格会教徒，然后她去了美国，她去了巴巴多斯，在那里她设法让总督……
to become a Quaker. And then she goes to Boston. And here she has a terrible time because the Bostonians don't approve of her at all. The moment she lands, she gets arrested imprisoned stripped her body is intimately examined by a perv for signs of witchcraft by a perv is that tom yes that's a technical well the person meant to be examining her is meant to be a woman but it turns out to be a guy who's dressed up as a woman's clothes so that he can go and have a grope no really so i think that counts as a perv freaky don't you think that's definitely a perv. Freaky. Don't you think? That's definitely a perv. Definitely. And all her books and everything get seized by the Bostonian hangman and burned. So it's all very sad.
成为贵格会教徒，然后她去了波士顿，在这里她度过了一段可怕的时光，因为波士顿人根本不赞成她，她一落地，就被逮捕、监禁、剥光衣服，她的身体被一个变态为了寻找巫术的迹象而进行了亲密的检查，被一个变态，是吗，汤姆？是的，那是一个技术性的……好吧，本应检查她的人应该是一个女人，但结果是一个穿着女装的男人，这样他就可以去摸索，不，真的吗？所以我认为那算作变态，怪异，你不觉得那是变态吗？那绝对是变态，怪异，你不觉得吗？那绝对是变态，绝对，她所有的书和一切都被波士顿刽子手没收并烧毁了，所以这一切都很悲伤。
And she gets put in prison and she's only saved from starvation by a friendly innkeeper. Because there's obviously something about her that appeals to this innkeeper. So I think that that bodes well for her prospects on Love Island. So anyway, she spends five weeks in prison and then she gets deported and they've only managed to get one convert. So that's very sad, but she's nothing daunted. So her next stunt is she goes off with five Quaker pals and they go off to convert the Ottoman Sultan. There are various issues there. Firstly, he doesn't speak English and Mary doesn't speak Turkish. And secondly, she's a Quaker and he's a Muslim. And also she's a housemaid and he's a Sultan. So all in all, the odds on them meeting up and getting on, I'd say are fairly low, but actually she does get to
她被关进监狱，只被一个友好的旅店老板从饥饿中救了出来，因为她身上显然有什么东西吸引了这个旅店老板，所以我认为这对她在《恋爱岛》上的前景是个好兆头，总之，她在监狱里待了五周，然后被驱逐出境，他们只设法获得了一个皈依者，所以这很悲伤，但她毫不气馁，所以她的下一个特技是她和五个贵格会伙伴一起去皈依奥斯曼苏丹，那里有各种各样的问题，首先，他不会说英语，玛丽也不会说土耳其语，其次，她是贵格会教徒，他是穆斯林，而且她是个女佣，他是苏丹，所以总而言之，他们见面并相处的几率，我认为相当低，但实际上她确实设法……
meet him and he's very polite and listens to her. And Mary says of him that he was very noble unto me. And someone writes about her performance here. She departed through that great army, that's the army of the Sultan, to Constantinople without a guard, whitherto she came without the least hurt or scoff to the commendation and praise of the discipline of that army, the glory of the great Turk and his great renown. So she's obviously got something. This impecunious, slightly mad housemaid has turned up and the Sultan himself has listened to her. She comes back. She meets with a sailor from Poole, marries him, he dies. And then she marries a guy called John Cross and they are together for the
见到了他，他非常有礼貌，听了她的话，玛丽说他对我非常高尚，有人写了关于她在这里的表现，她穿过了那支大军，也就是苏丹的军队，没有卫兵就去了君士坦丁堡，她到达那里时没有受到丝毫伤害或嘲笑，这赞扬和称赞了那支军队的纪律，大土耳其人的荣耀和他的盛名，所以她显然有某种东西，这个贫穷、有点疯狂的女佣出现了，苏丹本人也听了她的话，她回来了，遇到了一个来自普尔的水手，嫁给了他，他死了，然后她嫁给了一个叫约翰·克罗斯的人，他们在一起度过了……
rest of their lives. And they emigrate to South Carolina where she dies in 1698. And she is buried there with her beloved husband, John Cross, in the Quaker burial ground. And you can see her grave to this day. Oh, Tom. Sweet story. Very sweet. Katie, we've got one more. So the final person is the accidental heartbreaker.
余生，他们移民到南卡罗来纳州，她在1698年去世，她和她深爱的丈夫约翰·克罗斯一起被埋葬在那里，在贵格会墓地，你至今仍能看到她的坟墓，哦，汤姆，甜蜜的故事，非常甜蜜，凯蒂，我们还有一个，所以最后一个人是意外的心碎者。
So this is a man who's very joyous and charismatic, forms strong friendships with the girls, and then is fought over by them once they realise what a nice guy he is. Okay. Tom tugged at the heartstrings in the last one, and I've gone with an unexpected heartstring tugger, and a person who a lot of people will be surprised to hear me nominate in this category. So this is the former conscience of the Labour Party and of the Labour left, Tony Benn, the former Viscount Stansgate. Stung on his penis by a wasp. He was stung on the 6th of September, 2000, Tom. I had a bath this morning and I must report it, a wasp stung my private parts. It's been stinging all day. I could feel this thing flying around in
所以这是一个非常快乐和有魅力的人，与女孩们建立了深厚的友谊，然后一旦她们意识到他是个多么好的人，她们就会为他争风吃醋，好的，汤姆在最后一个故事中触动了心弦，我选择了一个意想不到的心弦触动者，一个很多人听到我提名这个类别会感到惊讶的人，所以这是工党和工党左翼的前良心，托尼·本，前斯坦斯盖特子爵，被黄蜂蜇了阴茎，他在2000年9月6日被蜇了，汤姆，我今天早上洗了个澡，我必须报告，一只黄蜂蜇了我的私处，它整天都在蜇，我能感觉到这东西在我的……
my pants and I tried to swat it and I probably did succeed and it responded by stinging me. Because that would be great on Love Island, wouldn't it? People would love watching that. That would go on Love Island best bits, which are the bits that don't make the main show. So Tony Benn is a very implausible candidate on Love Island because he's a man of enormous political piety and seriousness. So his father was a liberal and then Labour MP. His mother was a feminist suffragist theologian. He was in the RAF in the Second World War, though he never really saw action, but he was in the RAF in Africa, I think. He is motivated, as I'm sure Tom would agree, by this extraordinary kind of nonconformist
裤子里飞来飞去，我试图拍打它，我可能确实成功了，它通过蜇我来回应，因为那在《恋爱岛》上会很棒，不是吗？人们会喜欢看那个，那会进入《恋爱岛》的精彩片段，也就是那些没能进入主节目的片段，所以托尼·本在《恋爱岛》上是一个非常不可信的候选人，因为他是一个有着巨大政治虔诚和严肃性的人，所以他的父亲是自由党，后来是工党议员，他的母亲是女权主义选举权神学家，他在二战期间在皇家空军服役，尽管他从未真正见过战斗，但他曾在非洲的皇家空军，我想，他受到，我相信汤姆会同意，这种非凡的非国教……
religious passion. Although he's not really a religious person, but he pours all that in. But quite Mary Fisher. Yeah, very much so, Tom. He would love Mary Fisher. He pours it all into politics. When he succeeds to the peerage at the beginning of the 1960s, he fights this long battle to disclaim his peerage because he doesn't want it.
宗教激情的驱动，尽管他并不是一个真正的宗教人士，但他把所有这些都倾注进去了，但相当玛丽·费舍尔，是的，非常如此，汤姆，他会喜欢玛丽·费舍尔，他把所有这些都倾注到了政治中，当他在20世纪60年代初继承爵位时，他进行了这场漫长的斗争来放弃他的爵位，因为他不想要它。
So he was Viscount Stansgate, but he wants to stay in the House of Commons. He's the Minister of Technology under Labour in the 1960s. And then he has this kind of conversion experience where he goes way over to the left and he becomes Labour's Secretary of State for Industry in the 70s, where he loves nationalizing things. He dreams of a future in which hundreds of companies have been nationalized, in which men in donkey jackets are planning the future of the economy. In the 1980s, he becomes the absolute tribune of the plebs, touring the land, giving these incredibly articulate, rousing, inspirational speeches,
所以他是斯坦斯盖特子爵，但他想留在下议院，他是20世纪60年代工党政府下的技术部长，然后他有了这种皈依经历，他转向了左翼，成为了70年代工党的工业大臣，在那里他喜欢国有化事物，他梦想着一个未来，成百上千家公司被国有化，穿着驴夹克的人在规划经济的未来，在20世纪80年代，他成为了平民的绝对护民官，巡回全国，发表这些极其清晰、激昂、鼓舞人心的演讲，
not just against thatorism, but against what he sees as the heretics in his own party. But the reason I've chosen him is because he is also incredibly uxorious. He has this very sort of admirable and touching love story with his wife, Caroline. So they met over tea at Worcester College, Oxford in 1949. She's American, and she's also very left-wing. And he was smitten straight away. He proposed to her nine days later after they'd first met at a park bench in the city of Oxford, she accepted. Many years later, he bought that bench from Oxford City Council and he installed it in the garden of their house in Holland Park. And critics in the mid-1970s claimed that he was secretly having orgies at a rented house. And it was a story so utterly unbelievable and outlandish that it didn't even remotely catch on because he was the last person in Britain that would ever have done something like that.
不仅反对撒切尔主义，还反对他自己党内的异端，但我选择他的原因是因为他也非常宠爱妻子，他和他的妻子卡罗琳有一个非常令人钦佩和感人的爱情故事，所以他们在1949年牛津大学伍斯特学院喝茶时相遇，她是美国人，也非常左倾，他立刻就被迷住了，九天后，在牛津市的一个公园长椅上，他向她求婚，她接受了，多年后，他从牛津市议会买下了那张长椅，并把它安装在他们荷兰公园房子的花园里，20世纪70年代中期的评论家声称他秘密地在一栋租来的房子里举行狂欢派对，这是一个完全不可信和离奇的故事，以至于它甚至没有流行起来，因为他是英国最后一个会做那种事的人。
50 years after they had first met, she wore the same dress that she had worn that night. She kept it and she would come times, get it out and wear it on their wedding anniversaries and things like that. But the thing that's actually most touching about them is Tony Benn was an inveterate diarist. This is why he will, long after his political achievements, which were, I think it's fair to say, debatable, long after they were forgotten, he'll be remembered as this great diarist. And if you read his diaries from the year of her death and the year or so after she died, she died on the 22nd of November, 2000. And his diary entry afterwards said how heartbreaking he was. She was the finest person I ever met.
他们第一次见面50年后，她穿了那天晚上穿的同一件衣服，她保留了它，她会时不时地把它拿出来，在他们的结婚纪念日之类的时候穿，但实际上关于他们最感人的事情是托尼·本是一个根深蒂固的日记作者，这就是为什么他会，在他那些我认为可以说是有争议的政治成就很久之后，在他被遗忘很久之后，他会被记住为这位伟大的日记作者，如果你读他去世那年和去世后一年左右的日记，她死于2000年11月22日，他之后的日记条目说他有多心碎，她是我见过最好的人。
And then you read the next year's volumes. He's often saying, it was the anniversary of Caroline's death this week. I must say I'm finding it very painful. Not only do I miss her terribly, but I am riddled with guilt. The things that I should have done with her that I didn't. The next day, at six minutes past 10, the exact moment she died, we all went into the front room where I'd lit a candle and we stood in front of the picture of her and we hugged each other and took photographs a month later i was
然后你读下一年的卷册，他经常说，这周是卡罗琳去世的周年纪念日，我必须说我感到非常痛苦，我不仅非常想念她，而且我充满了内疚，我应该和她一起做但我没有做的事情，第二天，在10点6分，她去世的确切时刻，我们都进了前厅，我点了一支蜡烛，我们站在她的照片前，我们拥抱在一起并拍照，一个月后我……
listening to cassettes in the car and he's obviously thinking about his wife says i began crying and i sobbed and sobbed all the way to stansgate it was freezing cold there i sat in the bedroom and sobbed just comes back to you all of a sudden i wondered where caroline was has she disappeared into thin air what does death mean is it a complete and absolute end and he writes these kind of entries again and again but there is one nice love island touch to this which is about three years after his wife's death he meets somebody on whom i think it's fair to say he develops an absolute crush very implausible person and this is the first winner of strictly come dancing natasha koplinski so natasha koplinsky comes around to his house to interview him. She's a BBC breakfast presenter at the time. And he says in his diary, she did the interview. She's
在车里听磁带，他显然在想他的妻子，说我开始哭泣，我一路哭着到了斯坦斯盖特，那里冷极了，我坐在卧室里哭泣，它突然又回来了，我想知道卡罗琳在哪里，她消失在稀薄的空气中了吗？死亡意味着什么？这是一个完整而绝对的终结吗？他一次又一次地写下这些条目，但这对《恋爱岛》有一个很好的触动，那就是在他妻子去世大约三年后，他遇到了一个人，我认为可以说他产生了一个绝对的迷恋，非常不可信的人，这是《严格跳舞》的第一位获胜者娜塔莎·卡普林斯基，所以娜塔莎·卡普林斯基来到他家采访他，她当时是BBC早餐节目的主持人，他在日记中说，她做了采访，她……
very professional, exceptionally beautiful. Two days later, there was a knock at the door and there was Natasha Kaplinsky. You'd come around with a box of chocolates, which was really sweet of her. They keep up this relationship. June, 2004. I watched Strictly Come Dancing and Natasha won. She was doing a Foxtrot, I think. Oh, she was terribly good. And I sent her a little message. Later that month, Natasha came top again. Oh, she was so good. I voted several times in support of her. Then I rang her and said how fabulous she was. A month later, Natasha rang. She said she'd love to have lunch. I said, I've kept a month open for you. She said, only a month, Tony, which was very cheeky.
非常专业，异常美丽，两天后，有人敲门，是娜塔莎·卡普林斯基，你带着一盒巧克力过来，她真是太贴心了，他们保持着这种关系，2004年6月，我看了《严格跳舞》，娜塔莎赢了，我想她在跳狐步舞，哦，她太棒了，我给她发了一条小信息，那个月晚些时候，娜塔莎再次名列前茅，哦，她太棒了，我投了几次票支持她，然后我打电话给她，说她有多棒，一个月后，娜塔莎打电话来，她说她想吃午饭，我说，我为你留了一个月的时间，她说，才一个月，托尼，这非常厚脸皮。
Anyway, next Wednesday is settled. It goes on and on. They have the lunch. Natasha arrived at 4.45. She's beautiful and very friendly. I really enjoyed the evening. So that was a sort of sweet romantic friendship. I think it's fair to say that he developed in very advanced age. And I think those two things, the love story with his wife and then the late life platonic romance with Natasha Koplinsky, make him a compelling dark horse candidate for this year's Love Island.
总之，下周三定下来了，它一直持续下去，他们吃了午饭，娜塔莎在4点45分到达，她很漂亮，非常友好，我真的很享受那个晚上，所以那是一种甜蜜的浪漫友谊，我认为可以说他在高龄时产生了这种友谊，我认为这两件事，与妻子的爱情故事，然后是与娜塔莎·卡普林斯基的晚年柏拉图式浪漫，使他成为今年《恋爱岛》的一个引人注目的黑马候选人。
Yeah. So they never got together? Him and Natasha Koplinsky? Yeah. Well, who knows? Not that I'm aware of. I mean, Natasha Koplinsky, if she's listening will be able to yeah well there is a dance challenge so it sounds like Tony Benn would be completely undone by that maybe yeah
是的，所以他们从来没有在一起？他和娜塔莎·卡普林斯基？是的，好吧，谁知道呢？据我所知没有，我是说，如果娜塔莎·卡普林斯基在听的话，她将能够……是的，好吧，有一个舞蹈挑战，所以听起来托尼·本会被那个完全打败，也许是的……
unless Natasha Kowalski has given him dance lessons Tony Benn was a great crier as well so if you were to have a miners choir or something who started singing he would burst into floods of tears and I wonder whether that would also endear him to the audience katie oh definitely it was a challenge a love island challenge about nationalizing businesses or fighting the imf he'd win i mean he'd be all over that he would be absolutely all over that they haven't done that yet but never say never yeah i don't think prepare would be as good no no our opinions on international capitalism tom probably not as robust as certainly no probably not so katie there you have your eight contenders. Now you have to decide which of them are going to pair up with which. What do you think, having heard them?
除非娜塔莎·卡普林斯基给了他舞蹈课，托尼·本也是一个很爱哭的人，所以如果你有一个矿工合唱团之类的开始唱歌，他会泪流满面，我想知道这是否也会让他受到观众的喜爱，凯蒂，哦，绝对，这是一个挑战，一个关于国有化企业或对抗国际货币基金组织的《恋爱岛》挑战，他会赢，我是说他会完全沉浸在其中，他会绝对沉浸在其中，他们还没做过那个，但永远别说永远，是的，我不认为波培娅会那么好，不，不，我们对国际资本主义的看法，汤姆，可能不像……肯定没有，可能没有，所以凯蒂，你有你的八位竞争者，现在你必须决定他们中谁将和谁配对，你觉得呢，听了他们之后？
Instinctively, I'm going to pair up Peter the Great with Poppea Sabina, because I think she would be attracted to his name. She would see some opportunity in that. And he's also got a bit of a cruel edge like Nero, so I think they would get on. I would pair up Catherineatherine howard with sir william hamilton oh because i think she would see some opportunity to have some fun while also having a stable partner in the villa i like it yeah very good i pair up with charles ii because i think the producers will want that to happen because they'll enjoy her being humiliated over and over by him. Oh no.
本能地，我会把彼得大帝和波培娅·萨宾娜配对，因为我认为她会被他的名字所吸引，她会在其中看到一些机会，而且他也有点像尼禄那样的残酷边缘，所以我认为他们会相处得很好，我会把凯瑟琳·霍华德和威廉·汉密尔顿爵士配对，哦，因为我认为她会看到一些机会，在别墅里拥有一个稳定的伴侣的同时找点乐子，我喜欢它，是的，非常好，我把……和查理二世配对，因为我认为制片人会希望这种情况发生，因为他们会喜欢她被他一次又一次地羞辱，哦，不。
Poor Zoe. Poor Zoe. I feel a bit cruel doing that because she is my favorite actually, but it makes good TV, so it's going to be done. And then of course I pair up Mary Fisher with Tony Benn because I think Papaya Sabina will be attracted to Tony Benn and might try and ruffle some feathers. That sentence has never been said in the history of human experience. Until now.
可怜的佐伊，可怜的佐伊，我这样做感觉有点残忍，因为她实际上是我的最爱，但这制作了好的电视节目，所以它会被完成，然后当然我把玛丽·费舍尔和托尼·本配对，因为我认为波培娅·萨宾娜会被托尼·本吸引，并可能试图激怒一些人，那句话在人类经验史上从未被说过，直到现在。
You could have a million monkeys on typewriters writing for a million years and you'd never get that line. No. Right. Okay. So Peter the Great and Papaya Sabina, Catherine Howard and Sir William Hamilton, Emperor Zoe and Charles II, Tony Benn and Mary Fisher. Those are the four Love Island couples. And now Katie, am I right? The rule is that two people who are called bombshells get introduced. Yes, exactly. And there's a chance to see if people are going to dump the people that they're with and move on to someone else. So we're going to introduce a man and a woman. And both of these
你可以有一百万只猴子在打字机上写一百万年，你永远不会得到那一行，不，好吧，好的，所以彼得大帝和波培娅·萨宾娜，凯瑟琳·霍华德和威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，佐伊皇后和查理二世，托尼·本和玛丽·费舍尔，那是四对《恋爱岛》情侣，现在凯蒂，我是对的吗？规则是两个被称为“炸弹”的人会被介绍进来，是的，完全正确，并且有机会看看人们是否会甩掉他们在一起的人，转而选择别人，所以我们要介绍一个男人和一个女人，而这两个……
are friends of the show, people who have already appeared in episodes who will be familiar to lots of listeners. And the man that I have chosen is Admiral Horatio Nelson. Ooh. There's a history there. He's walking in. One eye, one arm, a victor of many battles, man from Norfolk. Burning with zeal for king and country. King and country.
都是节目的朋友，已经在剧集中出现过的人，很多听众会很熟悉，我选择的男人是霍雷肖·纳尔逊海军上将，哦，那有一段历史，他走进来，一只眼睛，一只手臂，许多战斗的胜利者，来自诺福克的人，为国王和国家燃烧着热情，国王和国家。
Yeah, king and country keeps him warm. And of course, Sir William Hamilton. Well, I mean, is he going to glare at Nelson? They get on, I think. They get on, yeah. They get on. So do you think basically any of the ladies, sorry, the girls, do you think that they might go for Nelson?
是的，国王和国家让他感到温暖，当然还有威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，好吧，我是说，他会怒视纳尔逊吗？他们相处得很好，我想，他们相处得很好，是的，他们相处得很好，所以你认为基本上任何女士，抱歉，女孩们，你认为她们可能会选择纳尔逊吗？
I think they'll all go for him, but he'll be attracted to Catherine because he always wants what Sir William Hamilton has. Yeah. History's repeating. Would Catherine go for him? Yeah, 1,000%. Of course she would. Sir William Hamilton, sadly, would be dumped.
我想她们都会选择他，但他会被凯瑟琳吸引，因为他总是想要威廉·汉密尔顿爵士拥有的东西，是的，历史在重演，凯瑟琳会选择他吗？是的，1000%，当然她会，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，遗憾的是，会被甩掉。
Oh, he's been dumped again. But I think he'd go very graciously. Or do you think that they would live in a ménage à trois? He'd still tag along. Yeah, he might be brought back, actually. He'd stand outside the bedroom. Yeah, exactly. Looking sad with his vases.
哦，他又被甩了，但我认为他会非常优雅地接受，或者你认为他们会生活在三角恋中？他还是会跟着，是的，他可能会被带回来，实际上，他会站在卧室外面，是的，没错，带着他的花瓶看起来很伤心。
Oh, no. Yeah, you can imagine the memes being made about him, I think. Oh, okay. So Catherine Howard and Nelson. So William has been dumped. So that is explosive action. But Dominic, who is the girl who's coming in? Top blood drinking, Christ marrying saint, Catherine of Siena.
噢，不。是的，你可以想象关于他的表情包会怎么做，我想。噢，好吧。所以是凯瑟琳·霍华德和纳尔逊。威廉被甩了。这真是爆炸性的动作。但是多米尼克，那个进来的女孩是谁？顶级嗜血、与基督结婚的圣徒，锡耶纳的凯瑟琳。
So Katie, your dad had been pestering to do an episode on Catherine of Siena for about, well, ever since the beginning of The Rest is History. She initially was very interested in fashion, wasn't she, Tom? Yeah. Loved fashion. And then had this sort of, again, a sort of conversion experience, actually, a bit like Tony Benn moving to the left after the 1970 general election. She casts off earthly things.
所以凯蒂，你爸爸一直缠着要做一期关于锡耶纳的凯瑟琳的节目，嗯，自从《历史的余味》开播以来就一直这样。汤姆，她最初对时尚非常感兴趣，不是吗？是的。热爱时尚。然后她有了这种，再次，一种皈依的经历，实际上，有点像托尼·本在1970年大选后转向左翼。她抛弃了世俗的东西。
She stops eating. Jesus visits her in her bedroom. They get married. She pledges herself to eternal virginity. She pledges herself to eternal virginity, which is an issue on Love, I agree. Loads of saints and stuff piled into her bedroom to preserve the wedding. I mean, these are dead people, like St. Paul and stuff. She married Jesus, using as a ring his blooded foreskin.
她停止进食。耶稣在她的卧室里拜访她。他们结婚了。她发誓要保持永恒的贞洁。她发誓要保持永恒的贞洁，这在《恋爱岛》中是个问题，我同意。一大堆圣徒什么的挤进她的卧室来见证这场婚礼。我的意思是，这些人是死人，比如圣保罗什么的。她嫁给了耶稣，用他带血的包皮作为戒指。
And then she carried out miracles, didn't she, Tom? Yeah. Stuff with bread and wine, healing people. She drank, what did she drink? Pus from the- She drank pus from a breast, a cancerous breast. I mean, that would be unusual. I mean, that's not the kind of thing I imagine that you get on Love Island.
然后她创造了奇迹，不是吗，汤姆？是的。关于面包和酒的事情，治愈人们。她喝了，她喝了什么？脓液来自——她喝了乳房里的脓液，一个患癌的乳房。我的意思是，那很不寻常。我的意思是，那不是我想象中你在《恋爱岛》里会看到的事情。
Anyway, so do you think that she might anyone yes any of the lads would I think she'd be brought in halfway through yeah in Casa Amor for Tony Ben to test his love with Mary Fisher but it will fail because he's exorius and so she will then be booted off Catherine Sienna didn't last long. Okay. Crikey. Yeah. Okay. Right. So the final couples therefore are Peter the Great and Poppea Sabina, Catherine Howard and Horatio Nelson, Empress Zoe and Charles II, Mary Fisher and Tony Benn. You eliminate them, Katie. So two couples go to the final. Yeah. So which are the two finalists, please? I think probably Poppea Sabina and Peter the Great because they'd have killed off most of the other stillborns. And I think probably Papyrus of Iron and Peter the Great because that would have killed off most of the other still ones
总之，你觉得她可能会，有人，是的，任何小伙子会吗？我觉得她会在中途被带进来，是的，在爱之岛（Casa Amor）里，让托尼·本去考验他对玛丽·费舍尔的爱，但会失败，因为他很狂热，所以她会被踢走。锡耶纳的凯瑟琳没坚持多久。好吧。天哪。是的。好吧。好的。所以最终的情侣是彼得大帝和波培娅·萨宾娜，凯瑟琳·霍华德和霍雷肖·纳尔逊，佐伊女皇和查理二世，玛丽·费舍尔和托尼·本。凯蒂，你来淘汰他们。所以两对情侣进入决赛。是的。那么请问哪两对是决赛选手？我想可能是波培娅·萨宾娜和彼得大帝，因为他们会杀掉大多数其他死产儿。我想可能是波培娅·萨宾娜和彼得大帝，因为那会杀掉大多数其他死产儿。
and I think probably Tony Benn and Mary Fisher Crikey what a showdown oh yeah what a showdown what a showdown I mean this will say
我想可能是托尼·本和玛丽·费舍尔。天哪，多么精彩的对决，噢，是的，多么精彩的对决，多么精彩的对决，我的意思是这会说明
so much about the British people won't it about the British electorate so they go for blood stained murderous head severing
很多关于英国人民的事情，不是吗？关于英国选民，所以他们选择了血腥、残暴、斩首的
dwarf tossing yeah and loads of articles will be written about it. What does it mean for Britain? Yeah. What does the vote mean? The cultural zeitgeist. Guardian will be going bonkers for Tony Benn, Tom.
扔侏儒，是的，会有很多文章写这个。这对英国意味着什么？是的。投票意味着什么？文化时代精神。《卫报》会为托尼·本疯狂的，汤姆。
They'll be writing one of their letter-writing campaigns. So, Katie, you have to decide not who you want to win, but who you think the British public would vote for. So, Peter the Great and Papaya Sabina, Tony Benn and Mary Fisher, given those two couples, who do you think the Love Island voters would go for? I think given the political climate
他们会写他们的信件运动之一。所以，凯蒂，你必须决定不是你想让谁赢，而是你认为英国公众会投票给谁。所以，彼得大帝和波培娅·萨宾娜，托尼·本和玛丽·费舍尔，考虑到这两对情侣，你认为《恋爱岛》的选民会选谁？我想考虑到目前的政治气候
that we're in at the moment, it has to be Tony Benn and Mary Fisher. Oh my word. Oh, what a turn up. Stunning. Tom, can you see Theo in the chat, in our producer just, what a turn up. Stunning. Tom, can you see Theo in the chat? Our producer just writing, yes, yes. In capitals.
我们现在所处的环境，必须是托尼·本和玛丽·费舍尔。我的天哪。噢，多么大的反转。太惊人了。汤姆，你能看到聊天里的西奥吗，我们的制片人，多么大的反转。太惊人了。汤姆，你能看到聊天里的西奥吗？我们的制片人刚刚写道，是的，是的。用大写字母。
The people's choice. The people's winner. Amazing scenes. And then you can imagine the Guardian writing about that as well. Perfect. Oh, the Guardian would be all over it. Yeah. Maybe the Guardian would sponsor Love Island.
人民的选择。人民的赢家。惊人的场景。然后你可以想象《卫报》也会写关于这个的文章。完美。噢，《卫报》会对此大肆报道。是的。也许《卫报》会赞助《恋爱岛》。
Yeah. Crikey. And people sometimes say that the Guardian would sponsor Love Island. Yeah. Exactly. And people sometimes say that the rest is history is not woke enough, Tom. I mean, what a rebuke. That's amazing. Yeah. What a rebuke to them. Yes.
是的。天哪。人们有时说《卫报》会赞助《恋爱岛》。是的。正是如此。人们有时说《历史的余味》不够觉醒，汤姆。我的意思是，多么严厉的斥责。太惊人了。是的。对他们来说多么严厉的斥责。是的。
Katie, that was brilliant. Thank you so much. Thank you. And I think everyone who's listened will agree that that was a rollercoaster. Yeah. Wow. Who saw that coming? With a stunning denouement.
凯蒂，那太精彩了。非常感谢。谢谢。我想每个听过的人都会同意那是一次过山车般的体验。是的。哇。谁预料到了这一点？有着令人惊叹的结局。
Right. And on that bombshell. Absolute bombshell. That succeeding Stanley Baldwin and the Empress Theodora are top Quaker Mary Fisher and top nationaliser of British Leyland, Sony Benn. Woo-hoo! We say thank you very much to Katie, who, as always, an expert guide to a world that,
好的，带着这个重磅炸弹。绝对的重磅炸弹。继斯坦利·鲍德温和狄奥多拉女皇之后，是顶级贵格会教徒玛丽·费舍尔和英国利兰汽车公司的顶级国有化者托尼·本。呜呼！我们非常感谢凯蒂，她一如既往地是一个向导，带我们走进一个世界，
as that review on IMDb said, a world of brainless morons and extremely sad and pathetic commentary on the current generation. Let's hope they're not saying that about this podcast. And we will see you all next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
正如IMDb上的那篇评论所说，一个充满无脑白痴的世界，以及对当代极其悲哀和可怜的评论。希望他们不是在说这个播客。我们下次再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。